welcome to the huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday
[Music]
life I'm Andrew huberman and I'm a
professor of neurobiology and
Opthalmology at Stanford School of
Medicine my guest today is Robert Green
Robert Green is an author who has
written more than five best-selling
books including the 48 Laws of Power the
laws of human nature and Mastery he did
his bachelor's training at the
University of California Berkeley and
the University of Wisconsin at Madison
Robert Green's books are both unique and
important for several reasons not the
least of which is that they explore the
interaction between the psychology of
self self-exploration and the psychology
of human interaction all rooted in
history and modern culture and at the
same time in a way that pertains to
everybody I first learned about Robert's
work from reading the book Mastery which
to my mind is a brilliant exploration
and a practical tool for how to think
about and pursue one's purpose purpose
whenever I'm asked for book suggestions
I always include Mastery in my top three
recommendations during today's
discussion we cover a wide range of
topics including how to find and pursue
and Achieve one's purpose we talk about
the selection of a life partner as well
as romantic and other types of
relationships we also discussed the
topics of motivation and urgency and
this concept of death ground which arose
during our discussion of Robert's recent
stroke Robert stroke rendered him
certain limitations but also has allowed
him to explore how to write how to
exercise indeed how to interface with
life in general in new ways that allow
him to continue to expand his sense of
purpose I'm certain that by the end of
today's episode you will have gleaned
tremendous amounts of new knowledge that
will allow you to navigate forward along
the path to your purpose perhaps find
your purpose if you feel you haven't
done that yet as well as to greatly
enhance your relationship with yourself
with others and indeed to the world
around you before we begin I'd like to
emphas EMP iiz that this podcast is
separate from my teaching and research
roles at Stanford it is however part of
my desire and effort to bring zero cost
to Consumer information about science
and science related tools to the general
public in keeping with that theme I'd
like to thank the sponsors of today's
podcast our first sponsor is Roka Roa
makes eyeglasses and sunglasses that are
of the absolute highest quality I've
spent a lifetime working on the biology
the visual system I can tell you that
your visual system has to contend with
an enormous number of challenges in
order for you to be able to see clearly
Roa understands those challenges and has
designed their eyeglasses and sunglasses
accordingly so that you always see with
Crystal Clarity Roa ey glasses and
sunglasses are designed with a new
technology called float fit which allows
them to fit perfectly and not move
around even when you're active in fact
whenever I'm wearing my Roa eyeglasses
or sunglasses I usually forget that I'm
wearing them I happen to wear Roa
eyeglasses at night when I drive or if
I'm reading at night and I wear Roa
sunglasses during the daytime if it's
very bright especially if I'm driving
into sunlight if you'd like to try Roa
eyeglasses or sunglasses you can go to
roka.com that's
r.com and enter the code huberman for
20% off your first order again that's
r.com and enter the code huberman at
checkout today's episode is also brought
To Us by Helix sleep Helix sleep makes
mattresses and pillows that are tailored
to your unique sleep needs now sleep is
the foundation of mental health physical
health and performance when we are
sleeping well and enough mental health
physical health and performance all
stand to be at their t one of the key
things to getting a great night's sleep
is to make sure that your mattress is
tailored to your unique sleep needs
Helix sleep has a brief 2-minute quiz
that if you go to their website you take
that quiz and answer questions such as
do you tend to sleep on your back your
side or your stomach do you tend to run
hot or cold in the middle of the night
maybe you don't know the answers to
those questions and that's fine at the
end of that two-minute quiz they will
match you to a mattress that's ideal for
your sleep needs I sleep on the dusk DUS
us mattress and when I started sleeping
on a dusk mattress about two years ago
my sleep immediately improved so if
you're interested in upgrading your
mattress go to helixsleep.com
huberman take their 2-minute sleep quiz
and they'll match you to a customized
mattress for you and you'll get up to
$350 off any mattress order and two free
pillows again if interested go to Helix
sleep.com huberman for up to $350 off
and two free pillows today's episode is
also brought To Us by waking up waking
up is a meditation app that includes
hundreds of meditation programs
mindfulness trainings yoga NRA sessions
and nsdr non-sleep deep breast protocols
I started using the waking up app a few
years ago because even though I've been
doing regular meditation since my teens
and I started doing Yoga Nidra about a
decade ago my dad mentioned to me that
he had found an app turned out to be the
waking up app which could teach you
meditations of different durations and
that had a lot of different types of
meditations to place the brain and body
into different states and that he liked
it very much so I gave the waking up app
a try and I too found it to be extremely
useful because sometimes I only have a
few minutes to meditate other times I
have longer to meditate and indeed I
love the fact that I can explore
different types of meditation to bring
about different levels of understanding
about Consciousness but also to place my
brain and body into lots of different
kinds of States depending on which
meditation I do I also love that the
waking up app has lots of different
types of Yoga Nidra sessions for those
of you who don't know Yoga Nidra is a
process of lying very still but keeping
an active mind it's very different than
most meditations and there's excellent
scientific data to show that yoganidra
and something similar to it called
non-sleep deep rest or nstr can greatly
restore levels of cognitive and physical
energy even with just a short 10-minute
session if you'd like to try the waking
up app you can go to waking up.com
huberman and access a free 30-day trial
again that's waking up.com huberman to
access a free 30-day trial and now for
my discussion with Robert Green Robert
I'm so happy you're here I'm really
really happy to be here Andrew thank you
so much for inviting me a short
story in 2015 I was teaching a course to
undergraduates this was a big course 450
students where was this this was when I
was a professor at University of
California San Diego I was about to move
back to Stanford um but the course was
entitled neural circuits in health and
disease but there was a final lecture
where I would do a lot of Q&A with the
students about science about careers
about career paths and what I found was
that many of the students had questions
about not just science but about how to
learn and forage for information yeah
and I recommended three books at the end
of the course every year that I taught
it I taught it for four years and one of
the books was the book longitude which
is a wonderful story about discovery of
timekeeping devices at c um one book
I'll leave as a mystery um not to be not
to be mysterious but because it's not
it's it's a science book I'll just tell
you what it is it's um uh principles of
Neuroscience so I thought that they I
don't know that one yeah it's a big it
makes a better a door stop uh for most
than than a book but it's it's a
wonderful resource um if you want to
learn about neuroscience and your book
Mastery wow and the reason I recommended
Mastery is because these students were
soon going to go into the great Jungle
of you know post uh undergraduate
education and and for me I found Mastery
to be an absolutely transformative book
in that it taught me so much about how
to learn from others how to expect
certain types of um interactions when
one kind of assigns themselves to a
mentor um and vice versa and it talked
about some things that we'll get into in
more depth today but not the least of
which is about identifying that um
unique seed that exists within all of us
that can guide our best decisions in
terms of finding our purpose and it and
so I will usually end with a great debt
of gratitude and I'll probably do that
again at the end but I want to start
with a great debt of gratitude than
Mastery transformed my entire life and
and in many ways this podcast probably
wouldn't exist were it not for Mastery
because um it really embedded in me this
idea that we all have uh a deeper
purpose and it explains how to go about
finding that purpose so I tell you that
and I also will use that as a way for um
asking you now since I'm sure people's
ears are pricked up to this you know how
do you find your purpose um could you
share with us what what it is to find
one's purpose and how early life events
perhaps can cue us to what that purpose
is for each of us well thank you for
that that marvelous introduction I'm
almost blushing that's that's fantastic
story um well you know being a human
being is not easy as opposed to an
animal because we're born and nobody
gives us like a direction our parents
might be a little bit our college
teachers Etc mentors but generally we're
on our own and it's a very very
difficult process you wake up in the
morning and you don't really know what
you're what you can do you could choose
12 different paths it can be very
confusing and very overwhelming when you
find that sense of purpose when you find
what I call your life's task everything
has a direction everything has a purpose
your energy is concentrated it's not
like you're just going down a single
narrow pathway it's not like life
becomes boring and it's just about
discipline and solving problems it's
actually the most exciting thing that
can ever happen to you because you never
have that lost feeling you wake up in
the morning and you go yeah this is what
I need to accomplish people come at you
with all kinds of distractions and
boring and irritating things you're able
to cut it out it's just the most
marvelous piece of internal radar that
you can have so I genuinely wish that
everybody can find that that kind of
internal radar and so it's not easy and
I understand that there's no like
instant formula because we're all about
instant formulas it's difficult and I
want you to know that so it's not like
Robert can give me the answer in three
minutes no I can't but there's a process
involved it's not it's not you know a
mystery you can follow a very singular
process and the idea is you're were
talking about
childhood the way I like to frame it is
when you were born you are a phenomenon
you are unique your DNA has never
occurred in the history of the universe
going back billions of years it will
never occur in the future your life
experien with your parents and
everything that you experienc in your
early years going on up is unique it's
yours you're one of a kind right so that
is your source of power to waste that is
just the worst thing you can do in your
life and what what the power is is
finding that uniqueness what makes you
you and how you can mine that and how
you can go deep into it and use that to
create a career path right and so I tell
people when you're a child when you're
four or five or even younger you have
what the great psychologist maslo called
impulse voices they Little voices in
your head that say I love this I hate
that I like this food I don't like when
Mommy moves this way I like when Daddy
comes from from here you're very CED
into who you are and what you like and
what you don't like and these voices
kind of direct you in certain ways
right and when you're very young they
direct you towards intellectual mental
Pursuits as well and there's a book I
recommend for everybody uh it's Howard
Gardner's five frames of mind it's
helped me immensely the idea is he talks
about five forms of
intelligence our problem is we think of
intelligence as most intellectual but
there are many forms of intelligence
there's the intelligence that has to do
with words there's abstract intelligence
that has to do with patterns and
Mathematics there's kinetic intelligence
that has to do with the body there's
social intelligence he has five of them
and the idea is your brain naturally
veers towards one of them it can Veer
towards two of them that happens but
generally one of them kind of dominates
right and it's like a grain in your
brain that's going in a certain
direction ction you want to go with that
grain and because that's where your
power will lie so when you're young if
you go back and think about when you
were four or five you you can maybe get
a picture of some kind of direction or
voice inside of you that was impelling
you towards this I know for me it was
words from I can remember when I was six
years old I was just obsessed with words
just the letters in Words almost like in
almost slightly schizophrenic way I
would spell words backwards I would take
them apart I would do anagrams I love
paland drums right so I had a thing
about words and language it's very
Primal some people you know Albert
Einstein when he was four years old his
father gave him a birthday gift of a
compass and he was just mesmerized by
this Compass the idea that there are
invisible forces out there in the cosmos
moving this needle and he's obsessed
with the idea of invisible forces Steve
Jobs when he was like seven or eight or
maybe younger in Berling game California
his father they passed by a store with
de technological devices in the window
and he was just hypnotized by the design
of those devices and the glass tubes and
everything so he wanted to go in that
direction you know Tiger Woods saw his
father hitting golf balls in the garage
and he was just like screaming with joy
he had to he had to do that right you
know I can give you a million different
examples of this of course these are
people who are famous obviously we can
go back and find that it's easier but
what happens to you and please cut me
off if I'm going on too long no please
continue please what happens to you is
you're seven now you're getting older
and you're starting to not hear that
voice anymore you're hearing the voice
of your teachers telling you you're not
good at this field you need to get
better at math you know you shouldn't be
interested in these sports or anything
you should be going this dire your
parents are starting to tell you this is
the career they want for the direction
they want you to go in right
you start hearing that more than your
own voice and as you get older it gets
worse and worse and worse then when
you're a teenager it's all about what
other people are doing your peers what's
cool what's not cool you know and that
kind of is more so all of these noise
enters your brain and you can't hear
that anymore you don't know who you are
and so you go to
college you kind of maybe choose a a
major that seems practical that your
parents want you to to go into maybe you
kind of wander around you're not sure
and then you enter the work world
without that inner radar that I'm
talking about and you brother you're
lost right where should I go well I need
to make money right and so you make a
choice based on the need to make a lot
of money some not everyone but some
people do that and I understand that
need we all need to make a living but
that can set you off on a very bad path
because you're not connected emotionally
the thing is when you figure out that
Primal inclination that grain that's
inside of you then you have the the
energy to to do to be disciplined to go
through boring tasks to learn you learn
at a faster rate because you're
emotionally engaged when you're
emotionally engaged in a subject the
brain learns twice three times four
times as fast as when you're not I
always give the example in college I
studied foreign languages which was kind
of a passion of mine for three or four
years I studied French and then I went
to Paris and I couldn't speak a word it
was it was useless because it didn't
teach me anything practical right I was
totally confused and then but I was in
Paris and I and I loved it and I wanted
to live there right and I had a
girlfriend and I needed to speak French
to her and I can tell you in one month I
learned more than those four years of
University because I wanted to because I
was engaged my emotions were there it
was like I had to survive to learn
French whereas so most of us we don't
have a need really to learn this subject
We're Half we're paying half attention
but when you find that thing that really
connects to you you're paying deep
attention your emotions are engaged
you're learning at a much faster rate
okay and so the thing is how do you find
that when you're older when you're 21 I
I I give people a lot of help and it's
usually not so difficult we can go
through that process it gets harder when
you're 30 and you've been wandering
around but it's not impossible I didn't
really start find my exact path until I
was 38 39 to be honest so there's hope
when you get 40 and you get 50 gets more
and more difficult right and it's very
sad if you wasted that seed of
uniqueness that I'm talking about and I
tell people there are ways of going back
and we go through a process like
archaeology we have to dig and dig and
dig and find those bones from your
childhood that indicated what you were
meant to do do but when you find your
life's task everything opens up it
doesn't mean you figured out okay I've
got to aim for this particular job when
I'm 28 that's not how it works it gives
you a sense of direction you can try
different things you can experiment you
can have fun when you're in your 20s
you're going to learn you're going to
learn skills but it gives you an overall
framework instead of whoa all this
confusion this chaos social media the
internet I could go here here here
you're lost at C it gives you a very
important sense of direction
Compass as you described this I I have
this image of um you know you mentioned
animals um that presumably don't have a
lot of flexibility in terms of the
niches they can exist in but the way I
imagine this process is that as a human
we're plopped into a environment and
here I'm using analogy where um we don't
really know if we are an aquatic animal
a terrestrial animal or a or an Aven
right or an amphibian or an amphibian
for that matter
um and to make the wrong choice right to
be an amphibian who's trying to fly
although I'm sure they're out there um
in the animal kingdom uh it it's not
just a waste of time it's probably
deadly um and not to overd dramatize the
the failure of finding one's purpose but
I see it that way whereas um perhaps we
could just say that the process of
finding one's purpose is to to realize
like ah you know um I'm an amphibian I
can go in and out of water whereas a
bunch of other creatures around me stop
at the water's edge right right and this
is really cool and a bunch of these
other things like these flying things
that they can't actually even go in the
water some of them might you know be on
the surface or dive into it but they
they can't do what I can do so the
process of self-discovery it sounds like
it's about um restricting one's choices
to a a a sort of wedge within the full
landscape of of options and um you know
for me I can certainly recall after
reading Mastery it helped me recall some
early seed emotions that I experienced
as a very distinct sensation in my body
can you describe that yeah um without
making it too um specific to my my
unique taste you know as a kid I loved
um flora and fauna I loved learning
about biology sure yeah no surprise
there um but animals and how they move
in particular and fish and going to a a
proper aquarium store for the first time
for me and going snorkeling for the
first time was like Wow and even as I
describe it it's almost like my body
floats I feel it in my left arm of all
things and it feels like there's
something to do about it it's not just
that I'm in observation of things that
Delight me right it's like there's
something there's an activation State
created within me like I got to do
something with this and typically it's
tell everybody about it until they won't
listen anymore um but oftentimes it's to
also draw those things to think about
them and I just Delight in them it's a
constant source of delight and so seeds
such as those and there are a few other
things in that in that landscape of
Flora and Fauna and learning about
animals and biology including the human
animal and then organizing information
feels so satisfying to me it's like a
drug that um and so it just felt feels
like this you know Eternal spring of of
life right and so for me that's what it
was and to and in 2015 when I was
teaching that course the course I loved
but I was feeling a little bit astray in
my scientific career and then I read
Mastery and I realized yes I love
running laboratory I love teaching but
there's something else for me and it has
to do not with a podcast I didn't even
know what a podcast I probably I knew
what a podcast was I was listening to
podcasts at that time but um but I
wasn't on social media I had no thoughts
of having a podcast but what I wanted
was that feeling in
its total number of forms that's the
goal get that feeling in as many forms
as possible right is that is that about
that's that's that's absolutely perfect
because the connection to what I'm
talking about it's not an intellectual
thing it's it's visceral it's emotional
it's physical right and you feel it in
your body and when you're doing it it's
like it's at your level it's like you're
swimming with the current you feel it
things are easy everything clicks
together there's a delight not
everything is going to be delightful
there's going to be tedium involved
there's going to be moments of boredom
but you're able to withstand the moments
of boredom because you feel that deep
overall connection so yes that's
precisely what I'm talking about I mean
it's for me it's a little bit a similar
thing is I said about words but the
other thing that I was obsessed with
when I was a kid was early human
ancestors don't ask me why I just was so
obsessed with our ancestors millions of
years ago and how it's possible to be
living here in the 60s or 70s with cars
and everything but to come to where we
are now and I wrote a a short story when
I was 8 years old about a vulture It Was
Written from the point of view of a
vulture watching the first humans kind
of emerge on the planet I'm sure it was
absolutely awful Dreadful but the weird
thing is I'm writing a new book and all
I'm doing in that book is going into ear
into early humans and I feel like a kid
again I'm so excited I'm so happy so I
can very much relate to your
story you mentioned these five different
forms of intelligence or frame frames of
Mind as you referred to them um and
I'm certainly aware that you know I lean
towards a more intellectual interests
although as you pointed out the the
excitement the Delight is visceral yeah
and the actions are actions they're of
the body ultimately right um one has to
draw speak write books Etc um to to
transmute that excitement into something
real for people that are not as
intellectually tuned but maybe are
kinesthetically tuned for instance um I
can only wonder what that's like uh I'm
not completely uncoordinated but I don't
think I have a kinesthetic Attunement uh
or frame of mind but I for instance um
had a podcast listener mention that they
think in feels that they literally
experience thought as a Ser as sort of a
patchwork of of bodily Sensations right
and that thought for them is not of the
stuff from the neck up but only from the
neck down which to me was really
intriguing
and so I only rais this because um there
have to be a as you point out there's an
infinite number of different sort of um
orientations based on our unique DNA and
experience but what do you
think explains why these particular
seeds or uh as you point out like the
the the direction that the grain runs in
the brain I mean it's it's partially
going to be nature it's going to be DNA
sure um but we we're talking about this
as if there's some exciting or a
inspiring or Delight ful thing that
captures us can it be the other way too
can it be um you know one has a bad
experience as a child in an intellectual
environment and then decides you know
I'm I'm going in the D things of the
body feel good if things of the mind of
intellect feels bad and does it matter
whether or not we are drawn to our
Purpose By recognizing what we love or
what we hate um or are both useful oh
they're both very very useful
um you know a lot of intelligence is is
not is non-verbal we think in terms of
images we're we're very much infected by
the emotions of other people so I know
for instance uh my mother is very very
interested in history she's obsessed
with history and I probably absorbed her
interest in history I don't think
there's a genetic a gene for that
interest you know so you're you're going
to absorb things from your parents as
well so it's not all
just genetic but yeah what you hate will
pay a big have a big thing but the
problem with doing that is if you go
into a direction and you're in you're in
elementary school Etc and they force you
to learn math and you hate it what it
tends to do is it turns you off from
learning in general you think I don't
want to I don't want to I don't want to
be disciplined I don't want to go
through anything because it's painful
doesn't lead anywhere it's not me
frustration it turns you off from
learning in general so it's it's really
really important for a child to have the
love experience as early as possible so
that they can know what they hate and
why they hate it right and then they can
Rebel and they can go into that field as
opposed to I hate learning I hate
discipline I hate studying I hate trying
things over and over again if you're
kinesthetically oriented and you know a
part of me I understand that because I
love sports is you have to you have to
practice it's going to take a lot of
it's not you're not going to instantly
be good at something right and that's
going to require a love of it right but
if your math experience CU I hate
learning you're not it's going to
transfer to sports you're going to hate
discipline in general so it's very
important for parents to let that child
have at least glimmers of that love
moment I know for me when I um finished
college and I entered the work world I
had to get a job I got worked in
journalism I hated it I hated working
for other people I hated office politics
I hated all the egos I hated the
smarminess I hated the lack of quality
it was all just about you know making
money and getting things out there and
then I worked in Hollywood I hated
Hollywood I hated working in Hollywood
that formed me very much made me go in
the direction that I went in but only
from the basis of I knew that I wanted
to be a writer so you know that's very
important that it's not just hate it can
form you but there also has to be that
positive deep emotional love of
something that also is grounded in you
in some way what you just said really
highlights the fact that energy and
motivation can come from either either
pressure you know desire for something
or desire to get away from something and
um earlier when you were talking about
um how we are so much more engaged and
driven toward things that stir us
emotionally and and actually we know
based on the the neurosciences you know
too I'm sure that um only by the release
of certain neurochemicals in the brain
and body would our brain have any reason
to change right if you don't feel
agitation and you can do everything that
you're trying to do of course your brain
wouldn't change like why would it right
that agitation is a is a signature of
the neurochemicals that are saying hey
something's different now right right
you might need to do something different
including rewire yourself right um and
that can come from positive or negative
experiences I'm obsessed with this ideaa
of energy I mean we all want to have
more energy and focus and normally we
hear about the concept of energy in the
context of caloric energy like what
should we eat and when and how much and
we need to get sleep but what you're
really referring to is neural energy
like the engagement of ourselves that's
you know uh sitting there ready to be
engaged but it requires the right
experiential macronutrients right the
experiential micronutrients as opposed
to of course we need good nutrition but
that's not sufficient it's NE necessary
but not sufficient so uh would you say
that when um we are let let's say since
a good number of our listeners are in
adulthood um you know from our 20s on
that the things that excite us as adults
that really generate some feeling of
Readiness or or grab our attention um
are still informative toward guiding our
decisions about best life and life
purpose well um what do you what exactly
do you mean by that I mean like because
there are things that excite you in in a
kind of a quick way like you know where
you have to relieve some tension and you
there's entertainment and there's things
that kind of give you pretty immediate
gratification and there's the larger P
picture of something that will give you
fulfillment over years to come so you
can feel that when you're older and you
can pay attention to it but a lot of the
time is we we're paying too much
attention to the immediate pleasures of
life to what gives us instant Gra
ification and that's what we're grabbing
for so this is a much more kind of
deeper process that involves that
digging that I was saying it it's it's
deeper than just kind of I like this I
don't like that you know kind of thing
it's it's more it's more something macro
than than just just that and so when
you're in your 20s or in your 30s or
your 40s you want to be paying attention
to yourself and the problem with people
in the world today is you're not paying
attention to yourself you're not inside
your own head you don't hear those
voices you don't hear what you love what
you like anymore because as I said
there's so many of these other
distractions going on and so you're
always like attuned to what other people
like right because you're in social
media this is what people are following
this is what they're interested in as
opposed to disengaging backing off from
that and and looking at yourself and
going through the process of that's not
me actually I don't really like that you
know and so what you're talking about is
I think very profound is levels of
frustration or anxiety are definite
signals that you must pay attention to
that they're telling you this isn't a
good direction for you this is a waste
of time for you and in general I tell
people selfawareness being able to hear
those voices to understand that your
frustration is telling you something and
sometimes you you just act on it without
understanding it but understanding why
you're frustrated why you don't like
your career why you're not happy about
where you're going is the key to
everything it will open up it will
actually be able even in your 30s to
return you to that childhood inclination
but if you can't listen to where those
emotions come from then they're useless
they're not teaching you
anything as we all know quality
nutrition influences of course our
physical health but also our mental
health and our cognitive functioning our
memory our ability to learn new things
and to focus and we know that one of the
most important features of highquality
nutrition is making sure that we get
enough vitamins and minerals from
highquality unprocessed or minimally
processed sources as well as enough
probiotics and prebiotics and fiber to
support basically all the cellular
functions in our body including the gut
microbiome now I like most everybody try
to get optimal nutrition from Whole
Foods ideally mostly from minimally
processed or nonprocessed Foods however
one of the challenges that I and so many
other people face is getting enough
servings of high quality fruits and
vegetables per day as well as fiber and
probiotics that often accompany those
fruits and vegetables that's why way
back in 2012 long before I ever had a
podcast I started drinking ag1 and so
I'm delighted that ag1 is sponsoring the
hubman Lab podcast the reason I started
taking ag1 and the reason I still drink
ag1 once or twice a day is that it
provides all of my foundational
nutritional needs that is it provides
insurance that I get the proper amounts
of those vitamins minerals prob biotics
and fiber to ensure optimal mental
health physical health and performance
if you'd like to try ag1 you can go to
drink a1.com huberman to claim a special
offer they're giving away five free
travel packs plus a year supply of
vitamin D3 K2 again that's drink a1.com
huberman to claim that special offer so
it sounds like one of the goals is to
engage in what I'll just call for the
moment unadulterated self referencing
you know unadulterated uh in the the all
senses of the word because um as a child
as you pointed out um at stages of life
that are before puberty they're
literally prex um which I think is
important right because um puberty to me
as a neurobiologist who started off as a
developmental
neurobiologist I can tell you that
puberty is the most profound
transformation that the brain undergoes
for sure in the entire lifespan there's
just absolutely no question about it
everything is different after puberty
because of all of the new relational
dynamics that become apparent and our
potential involvement in them yeah it's
just it's you know it's not talked about
enough how dramatically puberty changes
the brain sure I mean we are different
people before and after puberty hormones
that are suddenly raging the hormones
are there and it's not just changes in
how we view the world but changes in how
the World Views us and not just through
the lens of sexuality but also so um
expectation of what we are capable of
what we are responsible for or not
responsible for our learning capacity I
mean puberty is like this you know it's
also the most rapid stage of Aging in
our entire lifespan those kids that go
home for summer and then come back like
shaving you know I was sort of a late I
wasn't a late bloomer but I had a long
protracted puberty but I remember those
kids I'm sure we we all remember those
kids um everything changes and so I
think prior to puberty these seeds as
you described them of of delight or of
resistance to things think they are
unadulterated they're not contaminated
by the voices and expectations of others
and so I can see the challenge of
reaching back to those as an adult um I
wonder if this relates to um something
that I've heard you talk about before
although perhaps not as much as some of
the other topics you've discussed
publicly which is um the real versus the
false Sublime oh um could you perhaps
just Define for us what Sublime really
is what a Sublime experience is and and
the distinction between real and false
wow Sublime experiences because I I feel
like this relates to finding that seed
right it's it's about finding authentic
seeds of within us as opposed to when
emotions can be distracting and
misleading wow I never thought I never
made that connection and it's the book
that I'm writing right now so thank you
for that I have to think about that I'm
actually I'm writing a book on the
sublime and um I have several ways of
kind of illustrating I generally like to
use a metaphor and the metaphor is that
being a human being being a social human
being living in a particular culture
means that you live inside of a circle
and that Circle of that time are the
conventions of thinking of ideas that
are acceptable of behavior that is
acceptable this is where you where you
can go mentally where you can go
physically you know all the codes and
conventions so
that Circle for ancient Egypt and for
21st century America they're obviously
very different but it's the same Circle
it's the same limiting factor you're not
supposed to go outside of it these are
thoughts experiences Behavior you're not
supposed to do the sublime is what lies
just outside that Circle um the word
sublime comes from on the threshold of
it's like here's a door and the sublime
is literally at the threshold of the
door you're looking out into something
else right and the quintessential
Sublime experience is a near-death
experience you're standing on the on the
doorway the threshold of death itself
right and so in my book I'm illustrating
the different kinds of sublime
experiences that you can have in
relation to the cosmos in the relation
to thinking about being alive just being
alive is the strangest sensation you can
possibly have I have I know that very
person personally after my stroke I go
into childhood chapter on childhood and
how Sublime your own childhood was I go
into animals relation to animals I go
have a chapter about the brain chapter
about love I'm working right now on a
chapter about history okay but what I'm
trying to say is the human brain is
wired for these experiences is wired for
transcendental experiences that take us
out of the narrow little realm that we
live in because we're aware of our death
as the only animal truly conscious of
its own mortality and it frightens the
hell out of us and the idea that we can
see something larger than than just the
the the banal parts of our life is a
doorway that op allows us to kind of
transcend the moment to feel connected
to something larger to feel connected to
some power in the cosmos to Evolution
itself right and so we're wired for that
and I'm writing a chapter now about
40,000 years ago at the moment where I
think the sublime was born is a story
that I'm trying to illustrate right now
with our upper Paleolithic
ancestors so it's deep inside of us we
need it we have to have it in the 21st
century we have very few avenues for it
any real Avenues religion used to be the
main kind of way of accessing this and
so because it's so deep we reach for
false forms of the sublime that give us
the sense that we're we're transcending
but it's not at all because Sublime has
to come from within it's an experience
that you have that you're generating in
your own mind and your own experience
the false Sublime comes from outside it
comes from drugs it comes from alcohol
it comes from shopping it comes from
online rage it comes from joining a
cause and just getting out all your
aggression and violence right it comes
from causes it comes from
addictions okay it giv you a sense it
calms you down and makes you feel like
there's something else going on in life
besides your job that you're you're sick
of but it's not real it's not lasting
it's false it's an illusion it's not
based on anything real it's not
connecting to that deep part of human
nature that's wired for these
experiences so what happens is you have
to have more and more and more and more
of it you have to have you know more of
this rush you need more of the drug you
need more of the alcohol you need more
of the sex you need more of the horn
it's never going to satisfy you but the
real Sublime you don't have that feeling
it's like it's transformative once you
feel it it lasts for you for the rest of
your life it's what maslo again called a
peak experience so that's the difference
between the faults and the real Sublime
I haven't quite connected it to what you
were saying but if I think about it I
think you're on something very
interesting I mean maybe the connection
I was trying to draw was uh doesn't hold
but yeah for me
um those early experiences of seeing
things that just delighted me in a way
that felt like that not only is well the
the the thought process was a long time
ago when something like oh my goodness I
can't believe this exists this is so
cool this is the coolest thing and so
clearly create an activation state
within me but then there was also a
thought and a feeling of again a lot
this is or pre preverbal it's not truly
preverbal I could speak at that age but
it was um that's of me and I'm of it
right there's a connection there and
then it was there's something to do
about this the activation State created
in the body was you know I I need to
learn more about this I need to tell
people about this I need to think about
this I need more examples of this and
see whether or not they're all like this
you know etc etc um so certainly it
meets some of the criteria of a Sublime
experience definitely and I knew again
when I was in graduate school and again
when I was this young Professor about to
transition to tenure that I knew it was
going going to do something different it
was as if I was on the threshold of
something but I didn't know what that
next thing was but I could trust it
because of that early experience of
knowing that's the threat like like I'm
an amphibian this is my environment and
you're an amphibian too right and we're
different amphibians but you know we're
going to be amphibians together right
and then and there's a permanence to it
that it does seem to transcend time you
I'm obsessed with time perception so I
have to be careful not to go off on a
tangent about that but the human brain's
ability to F slice or macro slice time
is incredible and and it's been said of
um not just addictions but also
interactions with toxic people that they
murder time that that humans have a I
think it was young I I'll look it up but
um one of the great psychologists said
something to the extent that um
addictive behaviors thought patterns
substances are humans attempts to murder
time so that they don't have to address
their mortality yeah and that's always
made a lot of sense to me yeah we say
kill time is our expression kill time
through passive engagement but also kill
time through um trying to get
overwhelmed or overtaken by an
experience or a substance as opposed to
when you're truly connected you have
that sense of
flow and 3 hours can pass by and you're
not even aware of it so time is a
totally subjective experience it can be
extremely slow and tedious and you feel
very depressed or it can pass by but
that passes by without you even noticing
it and it's a wondrous experience you
know when I'm deep in my writing I'm not
aware of the time passing I'm so
involved I'm so immersed it's a deeply
deeply pleasurable experience of time it
is Sublime and yeah so I agree with you
I think your distinction is very
interesting you know I'm eagerly
awaiting your your next book but we
won't rush you well I I I'm I'm so
immersed in it that I could I could talk
for hours because I also have a chapter
in there about what I call the
dayon which is like that voice inside of
you that speaks to you and I'm writing a
whole chapter about how Sublime that is
when you connect to that voice so you
are spoton there is something very much
connected to Mastery in this book but
it's the next chapter that I'm writing
fantastic can't wait I can't wait I'd
like to shift slightly to a topic that
you've written extensively about which
is power um and not just power but also
seduction which you've written
extensively about and of course you've
written about finding one's purpose so
tell me if the framework that I've just
given myself Liberty to create is an
accurate one and if it's not I I'm
hoping that um it's not in perhaps some
interesting ways so to me you talk about
and we will talk about power as as a
resource it's it's something that um
it's there as a resource it could be
used or not used um and I think of
Seduction as one form of exchange
between an individual so there's a verb
associated with seduction power I'm
thinking of more as a noun in this
context you're the word guy um and then
you know purpose is uh is really about
finding like to what end or ends one is
going to um devote power seduction and
the other forces that allow human beings
to interact with each other in the world
um but power as a resource that can be
expressed in different ways and accessed
in different ways maybe we could just
explore that a little bit because you
know when we hear the word power I think
a lot of people kind of brace themselves
like here we go someone's going to try
and have power over me this is about
manipulation and so on and so forth but
I learned pretty early on that every
every career Endeavor there there are
power dynamics there's Mentor mentee
they teachers and their students and
both have power um in inter in romantic
relationships there's a power exchange
there are yeses and their NOS there are
maybe there are um uh covert and overt
contracts yeah I'll do this because I
want to right you'll do this because you
want to great sounds great overt
contract they're also covert contracts
well I don't feel safe doing that so
what I'll do is I'll take some something
on through from the interaction that
you're not aware of so that I can sort
of um ease my sense of danger and make
give myself the illusion of feeling safe
and all sorts of kind of complicated
human dynamics that have to do with us
having this forbrain thing that can do
all of that gymnastics so maybe we could
start very simply by just saying you
know how would you define power in terms
of its uh functional definition like in
in in interpersonal relations and then
why do you think
power is so essential to all
relationships that's really what I'd
like to get to why is it so essential
why couldn't it be something else well
the way I Define po is I try and take it
away from that kind of negative context
that most people have and that you that
you brought up and I bring it to
something very primitive and very Primal
the way the human being is wired the
feeling that we have no control over our
environment and in the earliest period
it was literally over our environment
and wild animals and nature and and the
climate Etc but now the sense that you
have no control over your career over
your children over your parents is
deeply deeply am miserating and it
compels us to act in certain ways either
attempts to find positive ways of power
or doing what you call covert ways of
getting power you know passive
aggressive traditionally passive
aggressive means so it's deeply wired in
US to want a degree of control over the
immediate environment and immediate
events we can never have complete
control and the idea of having complete
control is nonsense and it would
actually be very ugly because you want a
degree of Letting Go and letting
circumstances come to you etc
etc so the sense of you you you want to
feel like with other people and
relationships that you can influence
them that you can move them in a certain
direction either to get you to love you
and treat you better or either to stop
annoying irritating behaviors or either
to you know wake up and and find and and
and do productive activity if it's your
children Etc you want to have the
ability to influence people to move them
in a certain direction either in your
interest or in their interest right and
once you have that need and every single
human being ever who's ever lived has
that need and we often don't Rec
recognize it because we're embarrassed
by it we're embarrassed by our desire
for power for our need to control every
human being has it right and it's not
easy because human beings are
complicated they don't if you say do
this and you're talking to your son
he'll do the opposite or he'll do
something else you can't just force
people in a direction right by being
overt and telling them this is what you
need to do you create resentment you
create an enemy they may they may say
yes yes daddy yes husband I'll do what
you say but they're you they're they're
going to resist you deep down inside
right so people are tricky they wear
masks they pretend to say one thing and
they do another they have their egos and
you inadvertently wound their egos or
trip them in some way and they react in
a way that you don't expect and so power
is this kind of invisible realm that
envelops Society where people are
continually battling each other and
struggling in it but no one is like
talking about it no one's being overt
about it no one's saying this is exactly
what I'm trying to do and so when you
enter the social world in the career
world you're not expecting these battles
you don't know no one's taught you no
one's trained you your parents don't
train you nobody trains you and you make
mistakes and you realize how political
people are if you're a Sharky character
and there there's a certain percentage
of them you realize wow I can deceive
people I can manipulate them I can get
what I want I can pretend to love them
and they'll they'll fall for me and I
can do all this other stuff but for most
of us the 95% of us who aren't sharks
and I'm I'm including myself in that
category it's it's it's very very
disturbing to suddenly enter that world
and see all of that invisible power
games on that's no one's given you any
advice for helped you and so take it out
of the realm of it's just about trying
to dominate the world and manipulate and
exploit and and abuse
it's something inside of you you have
this need and your suppression of it
will only make you come out in passive
ways and you won't be able to control
certain things if you want to move
people if you want them to follow your
ideas if you want them to be more
aligned with your politics or your ideas
you have to be subtle you have to learn
psychology you have to learn certain
aspects of how to almost move people
without them realizing in in certain
directions which is like The Art of
Seduction and if you're not interested
in that if you're just going to tell
people what you think and what you're
going to do that means you're not
interested in Practical action you're
not interested in results you're just
interested in inventing your own
frustrations or your own anger so
learning the subtle little dynamics of
power is extremely essential because
we're a social animal it doesn't mean
that you're going to get dirty that
you're going to suddenly go out there
and manipulate the out of people most of
the 48 Laws of Power is about defense
but how to defend yourself from the
Sharks about there how to defend
yourself from making classic mistakes
like outshining the master like talking
too much like arguing with people
instead of demonstrating your ideas on
and on and on it's not an ugly thing it
actually makes you a better social
individual so that's how I I like to
frame it it's very interesting I I
think as a young guy growing up it was
so important to me um to know where I
fit in with my friend group um and I
didn't think of it so much as a
hierarchy um nor when I was in my
academic studies did I think of it as a
hierarchy even though it was clearly was
right um so much as it the goal was to
figure out where was my unique slot that
I could um do the most good for myself
and others right of finding my spot um I
don't want to say on a shelf CU that
gives an image of something vertical but
you know in the let's make it lateral a
lateral arrangement of different people
with different strengths different life
purposes trying to figure them out you
know where where should I be in order to
express that and also feel connected to
others and um and in order to do that I
did have to I realize now based on your
answer I did have to figure out um you
know who's trying to have power over
who's pretending that they don't want
power but is actually exerting power um
you know these sorts of things and
there's an incredible piece that comes
from knowing that one is in the correct
Place both profession interpersonally in
relation to oneself but also in the
context of one's peer peer group just
kind of yeah this is where I belong
because trying to gain power when one is
trying to move to a position that isn't
right for them or in a way that isn't
right for them just seems so
energetically costly yeah seems like a
waste of a life frankly right right you
know trying to gather resources simply
to to have them to give the illusion of
power but then being afraid of losing
them just sounds like a recipe for for
misery as you pointed out you know
whereas figuring out where am I most
powerful in the benevolent sense of the
word that that that seems like a good a
good Pursuit well it's connecting up to
to Mastery again and finding your life's
purpose you know I I I knew when I was
young that I couldn't exert physical
power
because I was a skinny little runt and I
was I wasn't bullied but people would
kind of pick on me etc etc so I veered
towards intellectual Pursuits where I
could have power and in the end you know
you might have been a jock and you might
have done well in high school but haha
Look at me now I'm not saying that it's
a beautiful thing that that's but that's
part of human nature the desire to
actually you know prove yourself and
find that Niche that you that you belong
to so you don't have that kind of hum
that sense of
inferiority which Alfred Adler the
psychologist describes very eloquently
so a lot of it is kind of compensating
when you're a child for things that are
your weaknesses and finding what you're
so good at that you do have that power
and people can't bully you right and you
you're you're like now a famous
neuroscientist whereas they're like who
knows what they're doing kind of thing
so power definitely is connected in some
way to that inner sense of what you were
meant to do and you feel it with the
with the ease and the connection that
comes from it right so I can honestly
say that my dislike of working for other
people and office politics and egos I
now have a of an existence where I don't
have to deal with any of that and I'm so
blessed and I wake up every morning and
I pray to God thank God I I found this
because it's it's the perfect lifestyle
for me yeah you're are can be accurately
Des described as an intellectual Beast
so it's um and which is like a
compliment right um we hear the word
beast and we think uh you know a
Ferocious Beast trying to harm others
but I'm happy being a beast yeah you
know so I think finding where we can be
a beast you know and and for some people
that's painting or or gardening or
whatever it might be um I think is again
ties back to the these issues of or this
quest of for
Mastery seduction is also a very loaded
word right it's even more more uglier
than power because seduction right
seduction kind of drips with uh the idea
that somebody is
tricking someone else into doing
something that they otherwise would not
want to do but seduction is both our
propensity to do it and to have it done
to us is hardwired into our nervous
system and has a lot to do with the
hypothalamus and a bunch of other areas
that I won't Bor us with the
nomenclature but um sedu
to me implies some sort of exchange I
suppose we could seduce ourselves
through denial or convincing ourselves
that of of something but more often than
not when we talk about seduction we're
talking about an interaction between two
or more people so um what are some of
the core principles of Seduction and and
if you care to play um Anthropologist a
bit um and a neuroscientist I I would
invite that why do you think we have
neural circuits in our brain that allow
us to seduce and be
seduced well um I don't know how if if
I'm if I'm being kind of an armchair
intellectual here but my my theory is
some of it has to go back to social um
events long in our prehistory which have
to do with
taboos and Society was initially kind of
organized by a series of taboos right
most notably the taboo on incest and
what happened is just not my theory it's
the theory of the malanowski malanowski
is I pronounce it um that the moment a
taboo enters the human brain like you're
not supposed to sleep with this woman
the desire arises inside of you to
actually sleep with that woman the the
the sense of no the sense that this is
prohibited stirs the desire stirs the
contrary impulses in humans and we can
be very um what's the word perverse
creatures right so if you've ever tried
to suppress a thought you realize that
it keeps coming up keeps coming up you
can't suppress it don't think of an
elephant Andrews whatever you do don't
think of an elephant you're thinking of
it because you can't help it right the
idea that you're not supposed to desire
of this person stirs that actual desire
so I believe the sense of something
being taboo and transgressive is the
ultimate kind of origin of our desire
for seduction but seduction involves
vulnerability it involves somebody gets
inside somebody gets under our skin
right and to do that we have to let them
in so the person being seduced is in
some ways to a degree complicit because
if you just put up a wall and you said
no I I'm not going to be seduced nothing
will happen but you have a vulnerability
you're letting that person into your
psyche Into Your Inner Space the
Paradigm for that is Early Childhood so
Freud talks a lot about this so I don't
know if people still believe in Freud
anymore I certainly do okay absolutely a
genius of both Psychology and Physiology
wrong about a lot of things did a lot of
things he shouldn't have done I let's
acknowledge that I think everyone would
agree that sleeping with your patients
and being a cocaine addict bad ideas but
at the same time he had an absolute like
near Supernatural levels of insight and
Brilliance into human nature he sleep
with his patience I believe he did um
but if I just if I just threw that on
him without him doing it then you know
uh forgive me certainly had emotional
attachments to his patients that he
shouldn't have had I don't know if he
slept with them he very well might have
but his idea was that the child is
seduced by the parent you're in
extremely vulnerable position right your
life depends on them and they're
seducing you with their energy you're
letting them in right and that kind of
creates a pattern for the rest of your
life and so for instance the feeling of
being carried by your father and just
being taken around physically is a form
of Seduction because you don't know what
he's going to do to you you're very
excited you want that surprise right and
to me it's related to the seduction of a
story stories are very seducing to us we
don't know where they're taking us we
don't know what the next chapter is what
going to happen to this character or not
the surprise lowers our resistance and
opens our mind up to what's going to
happen next is a form of Seduction fairy
tales the stories you were reading as a
child your interactions with your
parents they're deeply deeply ingrained
in you you cannot be seduced unless you
are vulnerable right and so I like to
switch it around and get out of the
negative connotations being vulnerable
is actually a positive trait I think a
lot of people now in the world today
because things are so harsh and invasive
that people have become too
invulnerable they don't want to let
anything in right and this now infects
their relationships with other people
they don't want to be influenced they
they want to be strong inside of
themselves they're afraid of giving in
to the other person of surrendering to
their influence but it's actually a
delightful feeling to surrender to the
power of another person and then reverse
that charge and have them surrender to
your power so when I'm reading a writer
and sometimes uh they completely seduce
me like friederick nich is one of my
favorite writers I let go of everything
I let him enter my brain and I'm
completely seduced I let him lead me
along but then I encounter writers that
I don't like at all I I'll mention one
you know it's probably not a good thing
but step Pinker I don't like St St
Pinker I find him really annoying okay
um but I force myself to try and find a
way to be seduced by him to let him into
my brain to see where he's coming from
to open myself to the possibility that
he could be correct so vulnerability
letting people into your mental space is
a form of intelligence it's a it's kind
of an emotional and an intellectual
intelligence and forgive me for
interrupting but I think it also implies
a level of confidence because empathy or
allowing oneself to be vulnerable to the
point where you're seduced by something
um by
definition if you're choosing to do it
uh implies that you also have the
confidence that you can get back to
yourself afterward right that you're not
going to get lost in the circumstances
you're not going to be hijacked to the
point of no return right or in some way
that's detrimental to you so it it's um
it I'm sound really nerdy here it's it's
cinear with with confidence in many ways
sure like take my mind
and take it where you will because I
know I can come back at any time right
right and the same thing in a physical s
in a romantic sense right you're opening
yourself up to the charm to the energy
of the other person but if they start
displaying dark energy and you see that
they're abusive or something is wrong
you have the ability to retreat ah well
there it gets tricky because very tricky
well because the attachment systems
which are also rooted in childhood um
often times can overwhelm one's ability
to recover oneself like I mean so I mean
how many if I had a dollar for every
time someone in that I knew in my life
saying like you know I know they're bad
for me but I just can't like we just
can't seem to disengage like that you
hear about that all the time I mean you
see court cases about this that are
public and you know you just go why
didn't they just walk away from one
another well because once those
attachment systems are locked in it
almost becomes in a and here
metaphorically speaking like a parent
child relationship like you can't
suddenly decide your parents weren't
your parents simply because you know
better now right you are forever
stricken with the reality that they were
and they had an influence and I think
that that attachment system is um is a
is a force that tugs pretty hard yeah
and um a lot of women have written to me
since the Art of Seduction sort of
saying that their boyfriend or husband
was applying some of these tactics on
them and it was very painful and they
were kind of a little bit angry at me
for for it but then they kind of
realized that they it wasn't they didn't
learn it really from my book it was
already kind of wired in them but that
reading about these tactics and these
strategies actually helped them to
recognize what their husband or
boyfriend was doing to them the
manipulation and the games that were
being played do men write to you and
talk about the seductive adornments that
women have used to to um bring them into
relationship as well or are you
typically hearing from women I mostly
hear from women complaining about men
and and and how they've abused them and
how they used
some of these some of the strategies I I
don't deny have a slightly nefarious
Edge to them because I didn't want to
write a book about Seduction That
doesn't have that taboo element because
I say seduction involves the taboo and I
didn't want to I didn't want to censor
myself but female to male seduction
clearly also exists less of I
acknowledge that it's um less often is
it physically abusive um but right I
mean from an early age both boys and
girls men and women are coached by
Society on the sorts of uh seductive
tactics and and adornments right I mean
everything from makeup perfume
hairstyles cars watches jewelry um
expression power displays of any kind um
I mean that stuff the world's filled
with that stuff yeah but men are
generally kind of happy when a woman
seduces them right they're unless
they're after their money or something
like that which happens but generally
the sense you know I talk about this in
in the first chapter about which I could
say is the quintessential archetype of
the female seductress the the kind of
half human half bird creature on a rock
singing so beautifully that you have to
jump in the water and then they kill you
and so the idea is that men want to let
go because men have to be so in control
so powerful they have to project this
image they have a secret desire to let
go and be almost dominated by a very
powerful woman a lot of men have that
and I talk about some of the most
powerful men in in history Julius Caesar
Mark Anthony um Joe dagio who all these
men very masculine men who've fallen for
very feminine siren likee women and been
completely dominated by them and they
actually kind of enjoy the process
because it's like a sense of I can let
go I can enter this totally s sensual
physical world and it it's extremely
pleasing it's like another realm outside
of my kind of cold mascul
world you know so I don't really get men
complaining too much about women who've
seduced them honestly it's usually the
other way
around I'd like to take a quick break
and thank our sponsor insid tracker
insid tracker is a personalized
nutrition platform that analyzes data
from your blood and DNA to help you
better understand your body and help you
reach your health goals now I've long
been a believer in getting regular blood
work done for the simple reason that
many of the factors that impact your
immediate and long-term Health can only
be analyzed from a quality blood test
now a major problem with a lot of blood
tests out there however is that you get
information back about metabolic factors
lipids and hormones and so forth but you
don't know what to do with that
information with inside tracker they
make it very easy because they have a
personalized platform that allows you to
see the levels of all those things
metabolic factors lipids hormones Etc
but it gives you specific directives
that you can follow that relate to
nutrition behavioral modifications
supplements Etc that can help you bring
those numbers into the ranges that are
optimal for you if you'd like to try
insid tracker you can go to insid
tracker.com huberman to get 20% off any
of insid tracker's plans again that's
insidetracker
docomo I've heard before um and I
promise this is not an original idea
that I'm pretending to have heard
elsewhere the my friend asked me to ask
sort of question that in all sexual
exchanges there's a power exchange
definitely um maybe you could elaborate
on that um because as you were
describing some of the seductive power
dynamics that ex IST a phrase that I've
heard before uh came to mind um that at
first made me chuckle but then made me
think um quite deeply about this issue
of the relationship between sexual and
power dynamics which is this notion of
topping from the bottom you know if one
is giving someone else the impression
that they are more powerful by virtue of
the word giving they actually hold some
power right power is can be given or
taken but um often times uh seductive
exchanges and sexual exch exchanges and
romantic exchanges in particular are
about both people
uh buying into a ill a temporary
illusion let's pretend that you're in
charge when actually I'm in charge okay
but I know that you think that you're in
charge okay let's just pretend none of
that exists and just do X right and I
think this is another example of covert
contracts and it's one that actually can
potentially create a lot of problems
post Hawk right um but I think the
relationship between sex romance and
power is an important area to explore in
the context of this well I wrote The Art
of Seduction with the idea that it was
an art invented by women it was invented
by women who had no power essentially
socially politically in any sense of the
word in in in domestically
right and but the one power that they
could that they could wield over a man
was through sex
some physical attraction and so they
develop this art of kind of luring a man
into their world through various
theatrical effects Cleopatra being kind
of the archetype of this and then luring
the the powerful man into this world he
has the illusion that he's the one
pursuing her but in fact she is the one
controlling the dynamic so often times
the person who appears to be the weaker
one in the relationship who's not doing
the pursuing is actually inviting the
pursuing is actually leading the other
person on so there's a lot of kind of
appearance games going on and you can
never really figure out who exactly is
in control of the dynamic because one
person is
like allowing the other person to lead
them on but the fact that you're
allowing them is a degree of power is a
degree of control right so it's very
hard to figure out and sex and power and
romantic relationships are very much
intertwined in US physically emotionally
neurologically you can't avoid it right
and so I think it's kind of dishonest to
say that that none of that exists that
it's like that there's some egalitarian
Paradise out of there when it it's
really not wired in us for that kind of
relationship there's a recent scientific
publication SL factoid that I want to
share with you in this context because
I'd like your thoughts on it uh David
Anderson who's a phenomenal
neurobiologist he's been a guest on this
podcast before he's a professor at
Caltech studies um basically the
functions of the hypothalamus so okay
things like uh aggression mating and and
things of that sort um and does it so it
in with great detail he's a virtuoso of
the hypothalamus and he published a
paper two years ago showing that indeed
there are neural circuits in the brain
of animals and presumably in humans as
well that control sexual mounting
Behavior but that there is actually a
separate circuit for
purely nonsexual mounting and physical
power over that's expressed in animals
and anyone that's ever owned a dog and
gone to the dog park will see same-sex
mounting between dogs or mounting
between dogs that has apparently um no
sexual end point yeah and in exploring
this lit and some talking to David about
it it's very clear that there are neural
circuits um that have everything to do
with essentially one animal of a species
getting on top of the other animal
usually from behind often times
scruffing or biting the back of the neck
and saying I control you it's a it's
often done in a playful context
especially between animals not always
aggressive but there's a certain element
of aggressive to it but essentially says
I decide whether or not you are mobile
or not for this moment and that it and
this is very important I want to
emphasize this this is a circuit that is
entirely separate from all of the
reflexes associated with sexual behavior
in males and females I find this to be
fascinating um and because we hear about
power over right and we hear about power
and we think about physical power over
but the idea that something as primitive
as mounting just like something as
primitive as biting or as
striking has its own unique set of
circuits in the brain I think
substantiates every everything that you
put in uh in your books about power and
maybe even seduction as well so as I
just kind of toss that out there for
consideration I I I wonder um if you
have any Reflections on it if not um
feel free to just say I don't but of
course but to me this was a really
important Discovery because I think
everyone looks at mounting behavior and
says oh that has to be sexual and
sometimes it's oh I see what you mean
but but it's not that there's a there
seem to be a host of neural circuits in
the brain that are are really about
defining who's on top literally that has
nothing to do with
sex yeah I'm sure that's true I've never
I've never I've never um read anything
about that but I can say that um I wrote
a chapter in in my new book about love
and that's a different thing than than
seduction and I was trying to come up
with an idea of love that does have an
element of equality that doesn't have
this power dynamic going on in it I love
that and um you know kind of like the
antithesis of my Art of Seduction where
I'm almost contradicting myself and I
was going into the into the biology of
it and even into the physics of it so
there is a famous uh French biologist
whose Name Escapes me I'm sorry I can't
remember from the 20s and 30s um and he
was studying
parium and he found he was studying them
you know they they're in these ponds Etc
and he said that there was these moments
where these single celled organisms were
suddenly coupling they were all joining
together just one to one and they were
absorbing the membrane of one inside the
other and then they would like go and
then once one couple did that all the
parium started joining up together then
they would sink to the bottom of the
pond and parium don't reproduce through
sex they reproduce through dividing
themselves right self
reproduction and so he was saying that
the desire to couple to to to connect to
someone so deeply where you absorb one
is absorbed in the other is biologically
wired into US goes back millions and
millions and millions of years and it's
a desire essentially a biological desire
for love right and it's an energy that
permeates all all the it's it's not just
about power and hierarchy
and that he was showing other creatures
that had something similar going on and
you know in physics we talk about
entanglement and we also talk about um
you know matter if matter isn't absor
isn't um opposed by a lot of kinetic
energy it joins together I mean
particles join together to form matter
etc etc so there's something in the
universe that's trying to connect things
to each other so there's this this kind
of energy that exists in the world where
we have a deep need to connect to
somebody with outside of those power
dynamics right where there's a degree of
equality where we're drawn to each other
and we let go of the ego games we let go
of the playing we kind of surmount our
own physiology our own
hypothalamus and we engage in this I
call it love Sublime and it involves the
physical part the sexual part is the
trigger for it because when you have sex
with someone your body is suddenly
permeable to their energy in a way that
you cannot control it releases all kinds
of of chemicals in the brain that are
very powerful and oftentimes that sense
is too powerful and you react and you're
afraid of it and you pull back but if
you don't react and you go further then
the mind also becomes permeable to the
other person and their energy and their
desire and so then
it kind of creates a spiraling effect
where the physical and the mental
connection reaches this state that I
call love Sublime now it's an ideal it
doesn't really exist that much out there
in the world today but there are stories
in history that illustrate it and I
believe that is a biological necessity
for us to feel a deep deep sense of
connection we normally ascribe that to
religion to God Etc but I maintain the
essence of love the model for for love
is between two human beings straight or
homosexual doesn't matter and that
feeling of surmounting our own neurology
our own system and and entering this
zone is deeply deeply satisfying we all
want it and it has to involve letting go
of the power dynamics letting and
everything being equal it's not that the
other person is exactly like you you
recognize their difference but but as
far as being worthy of attention being
worthy and
respected you leave all that other stuff
outside so there is a Zone that's
possible that's outside this power denam
that we're talking about I'm excited
that you're writing about this uh so
this is for your next book yeah I'm very
excited I couldn't help but think of
some of the parallels between what you
describe and what we're observing
nowadays in the landscape of politics
and social dynamics where clearly um
they is no setting aside of egos people
feel both sides feel attacked everyone
in between feels confused like why do I
have to pick aide um and there seems to
be no hint of a future where people are
setting down their swords it which means
if we were to go with your earlier
definition which I like a lot that um
nobody feels safe enough to be
vulnerable enough to um to allow the
union of of people to occur which is
just a way a way of rewarding you know a
bunch of other things um and not nearly
as eloquently as as you described it but
if setting aside of power dynamics and
making oneself vulnerable is is the key
to accessing love in the Romantic
context surely but also in the um
societal context I mean what are the
channels for that I mean I suppose there
is the argument not mine that everyone
should just take a boatload of
psychedelics and see the
interconnectedness of things but that
seems like an realistic route I I just
don't see that being you know um you
know 12th grade graduation um curriculum
um nor do I think it would be healthy I
to be clear I think that you we'd end up
with a lot of expression of of problems
there um but short of a magic substance
that could increase feelings of uh
connectedness among everyone
simultaneously um how are you going to
save Humanity Robert well um because I'm
I'm concerned about young people in
particular with hookup culture with
pornography etc etc it's kind of
rewiring the human brain and we're
losing what I was just describing and I
see aot particularly a lot of young
people and I don't blame them because
they've grown up in a world that's very
chaotic and very hostile could could I
say I think it's um and not to be
nitpicky here but I I love what you just
said I think in my mind it's hi things
like that are hijacking the hard wirring
of the brain okay um and I'm just I'm
again forgive me my the audience is
probably going can't really rewire the
brain like that so well I think we can
expand and rewire Upon Our hard wiring
but so much of what you you talk about
in your books is about finding one's
Essence but then also what I love about
your books so much among many other
things is that it's about that dance
between the hard wiring and and the
possible of through effort so anyway
forgive me for for being it's very
accurate so yeah what how do you get us
out of this well you're putting a big
burden on me I am but I think you're up
to it you know um well I try to do it in
this chapter because I wanted to seduce
the reader into the idea that this is
something extremely pleasurable and
extremely healthy and the feeling of
being vulnerable is a very positive
attribute that will infect not just your
romantic relationships but will infect
you mentally so creative people are
extremely vulnerable they're extremely
vulnerable to ideas they're extremely
vulnerable to the environment and
closing yourself off into your own ego
into yourself so the chapter is called
Escape the Prison of the egoo and you're
you're kind of trapped inside of
yourself and your own thoughts and your
own desires and it's like a prison it's
enclosing you and you want to escape
somehow and you escape through drugs you
escape through porn but it doesn't lead
to actually escaping you want to be able
to let go of the self and get out of
this this prison that you're in right
and so it's a desire that that we all
have and so I wanted to frame it as this
incredibly positive Dynamic that you can
engage in and the ability to be
vulnerable to other people to open
yourself up and to say that yeah they
might hurt me but I'm strong enough to
take it and if they hurt me I'll learn
from it and I'll rebound and I know
that's a bit naive on my part but I want
you to at least have that feeling
because a lot of young people write to
me and they say I I can't fall in love
anymore I can't I don't like that
feeling I it makes the loss of control
is too much you know and and a lot of
that their behavior patterns are in
creating this sense of control which you
can have when you're locked inside of
yourself uh hence over indulgence in
pornography yeah and masturbation
Etc as a way to avoid the you know the
understandable fear about inter
relational Dynamics yeah yeah so you
know when you're young you're you're
idealistic at least a lot of young
people are and you have these dreams and
these hopes and to let go of this
possibility which is deeply pleasurable
and deeply therapeutic to the human
animal as a social animal it's like the
highest form of interaction that we can
have so my strategy in that chapter was
to paint such a wonderful portrayal of
the pleasures that are awaiting You by
letting go of your defenses of letting
go of all of your natural resistance
factors and opening yourself up to other
people is is a key to not just a
romantic relationship but to Career
Success to mental energy to creativity
to being open in general right and
so I don't think I could have a a wi you
know a huge impact but we'll see when
the when the book comes out but I'm
advocating that sense of open opening
yourself up to the universe to the
cosmos itself as an energy that
permeates the world and so that you
don't want to the feeling of being
closed inside of your ego inside of your
yourself I want to make it so you feel
the pain of that because you don't
really feel the pain of it you feel like
it's comfortable for you but I want to
make it clearity that it's not
comfortable it's deeply deeply painful
and it's disconnecting you from some of
the best experiences you can have in
life so I have that strategy the only
other hope I have is in the human Spirit
itself so a lot of this is being caused
by social media I believe right um and
uh and the instant and the the kind of
immediate gratification we can get in so
many ways and my hope is that young
people get fed up and get dis disgusted
with all this disconnection an
alienation in their life and that they
hunger from actually something more
communal more interactive more real as
opposed to Virtual and so that the human
Spirit can't be completely squashed by
technology Etc so I have that hope
because we've gone through these Cycles
before in history where people have
become very invulnerable and very locked
and closed and suddenly there's an
explosion a creative explosion like in
the 1960s like in the 1920s like in 18th
century Europe with the Casanova and the
where seduction reached its kind of apy
Etc so it has kind of swung back and
forth between these moments where humans
get incredibly closed and bitter and
partisan and everything's conflict and
everyone's divisive Etc and suddenly
goes in the opposite
direction I I have hope in that
possibility and I structured my chapter
to perhaps sweep that a little bit along
that tie and see if I can have any
effect well I think what you just
described in conversations like it and
that stem from it are likely to have a
tremendous effect I think it's exactly
what's needed now and um certainly I'll
be uh to amplify that message I I agree
with everything you said and not just
because you're sitting here as a guest
uh on this podcast but because um it's
clear to me that while power dynamics
and seduction are um wired into our
human relations since the beginning of
time that we have reached a a very
challenging period in our history um
it's somewhat of a relief to me to know
that it's happened before but in a very
different context uh we hear a lot about
The Swinging back and forth of the
pendulum uh someone in fact uh Peter
Atia online Physician's brother actually
said I um so we'll credit him he said no
it's not a it's not a pendulum that
swings back and forth unfortunately now
it's become a wrecking ball so it's
swinging back and forth and doing damage
as it as it reaches its um you know it's
extremes and I think that um I also look
forward to a time where people
um acknowledge the the injustices around
them and and that have been done to them
and others and um but somehow are able
to transcend that and the word that I'd
like to pick up on there is the word
justice um it was pointed out to me uh
by someone I respect very much that you
know having a sense of justice is a is a
wonderful and important thing and as
humans it's important to how we
structure Society but I do think that
that a lot of the negative things that
we see out there nowadays are have
something to do with the availability of
uh ready availability of pornography
high density calorie food Etc a bunch of
things like that but that one of the
issues with social media because it does
have its positive aspects but one of the
negative issues in my mind is that it's
a steady flow of um examples of
Injustice so all day long you're just
seeing things like that that piss you
off and that piss other people off and
for different reasons but but what was
pointed out to me is that one of the key
things about a sense of Injustice is to
be able to determine whether or not
there's anything that you should do
about it and I think that everyone now
feels a bit hijacked by all the
injustices we see because we feel like
well we're supposed to do something
about it but it may be that while we
can't let every Injustice pass that
being bombarded all day long with things
that upset us is hijacking our
creativity it's distracting us from our
deeper purpose it's preventing a sense
of vulnerability that would lead to a
sense of deep love and on and on so I
don't think it's just about the The Lure
the tantalizing lures of of sex food and
um and looking at you know bodies and
hearing voices on social media I think
there is some validity to that but that
it's also that you know there's just
ample opportunity to go down the
gravitational pole forces of Injustice
like H that's so frustrating why are
they doing that I mean I catch myself
doing that talking to co-workers when I
walk in about did you see this thing
this is crazy what's going on with it
they're crazy when you know as opposed
to thinking about anything else in that
moment and I try and yank myself out of
that but I I think that um you're not
going to do it alone but I think you
will play a major role in saving us from
this because people I do I think because
people just need to see themselves
through a different lens and realize
this is distracting me from who I'm
supposed to be well a lot of what what
modern life should involve is the
ability to ignore certain things so for
instance since I don't know if you know
that app next door oh right I used to
have it but then I'd see all the the
packages being stolen off my neighbor's
porches in Oakland and then I started
enjoying living in Oakland less and I
love the city of Oakland it's got its
problems it definely has its problems
but as an East Bay kid you know and went
to school out there and you know like I
have deep love for the East Bay and it
it's always had those problems but when
you see stuff being stolen on your phone
in the middle of the night when you wake
up it creates a sense that like they're
out to get my stuff it's terrible right
and so uh I have it in my spam filter
but I look at it and and every headline
is people stealing somebody broke into
somebody's house this P dog bit me this
this rapid dog going around there's this
homeless person that's yelling and
attacking people on and on and on I feel
like I'm living in this neighborhood
it's like Beirut or something in the
1980s I can't even walk out my door I
just got I don't look at next door
anymore I just ignore it I don't open it
ever because I know that that they're
designed algorithmically to put that in
front of you every single time so that
you click on it because that's we
respond to that kind of stuff naturally
we can't help it so you have to be able
to shut that stuff up and look at what
you can actually control in your life so
I have this visceral dislike of what's
going on in Ukraine because I was in
Ukraine recently and I feel I've
identified very strongly with their
struggle right and it just I can't that
outrage feeling it just every time I
read an article about it it just drives
me crazy so the only thing is I stop
reading as much as I can I read things
that are kind of rational and
intelligent and I send the money and I
you know I donate as much as I can and I
help them practically but I don't allow
myself to get that kind of outraged
feeling all of the time so somebody has
to write a book somebody has to instruct
us and what to ignore and what to
actually pay attention to so there are
things that you can control
injustices that are out there that you
could control by voting by certain by
amassing a movement by you know dealing
with climate change not by trying to
recycle every little thing in your house
but actually doing something really much
more macro in the world you know joining
a cause there are things you can do and
that's positive and that's a way of
channeling that kind of dark energy in
you for a positive purpose but it's
totally disruptive and it totally
distracts you and weakens you and drains
you of energy to fall into those rabbit
holes and let them and let yourself fall
into them so you have to learn the art
of what to ignore and what not to pay
attention to and understand that you're
wired to see those kind of red alert
buttons on Facebook or on next door
wherever they are and it it's just it's
it's it's negative it's like a candy
rush and you have to avoid it and it's
taking us away from our purpose which we
each have I mean I think to me that's
the the most um delerious aspect unless
unless your purpose is to organize and
be an activist people ask me I wrote a
lot about in my human nature book about
the shadow side of human nature right
and we all have it we all have a dark
side we all have hidden aggression we
all have feelings of Envy we all have
feelings of grandiosity we all have
aggressive impulses how do you deal with
it and I say the way to deal is to
channel it into something positive and
pro-social and that could be putting it
in your artwork venting that anger and
that outrage and something that people
kind of can identify with or it can be
an organizing something that could be
your purpose in life and actually doing
something positive so that's the only
way that you could actually use that
energy for some kind of actual life's
task or purpose you've been discussing
ing lately a bit on some of your
channels about masculine and feminine um
let's say roles um and crisis of the
masculine feminine dance as well as the
crisis of masculinity per se the crisis
of femininity per se um do you care to
expand on that a bit I think um we could
probably take three four hours to
explore all this in full um but I was
struck by some of the things that you
said um because I agree completely that
um just as we are not given a road map
When we arrive in the world as to how to
find our purpose I think there's also a
very conflicted road map that's thrown
in front of us and indeed conflicting
multiple road maps about what it means
to be masculine or feminine or some
combination of both which of course
everybody is some combination of both
just to varying degrees well um yeah so
men have a feminine side to them which
if you try to repress it will come out
in other ways and women have a masculine
side to them I think Yung describe this
very well with the anima and the Animus
which I think is is extremely
real um it's very very confusing times
for both men and for women right now we
don't know the roles that there there're
everything is just so fluid and it's
very very difficult particularly if
you're young so young women are getting
this idea that everything should be
equal and that women should have and of
course it's right should have be paid
the same and should have the same career
opportunities there should be no
Prejudice or harassment or anything but
at the same time on social media it's
all about looking perfect and looks are
are incredibly important and if you're
not hot you're in terrible trouble and a
lot of young girls are extremely
confused by this they're getting mixed
signals right and boys are even in
perhaps even worse circumstances where
being masculine is seen as something
negative so we don't have any ideals out
there anymore of what what
constitutes a good positive form of
femininity and a good positive form of
masculinity in fact we even think that
there shouldn't be anything like that
there's no such thing as being masculine
or feminine whatever it's very very
confusing and so you know I I think of
of of masculine traits that I think are
very positive and that should be out
there to kind of counteract the sort of
Andrew Tate seduction that a lot of
young men are falling for and it's a
kind of an inner strength where you're
sort of in control of your emotions
you're not invulnerable etc etc but um
you can take
criticism you can take PE you you know
you can have moments of failure and
you'll bounce back but you have a kind
of res inner resilience and a kind of
inner strength a kind of a quiet calm
that I think used to be exemplified in
movie icons like a Gary Cooper type
thing right and that kind of sense of
inner calmness where you're not
hysterical you're not getting upset
about everything that happens where you
have a kind of an inner strength and a
confidence and you can withstand kind of
what Ryan holiday talks about a lot
about with stoicism you can withstand
all of the hardships in life but you
have that Citadel Within you is a very
very powerful form of masculinity as
opposed to it's all about sleeping with
a lot of women having really fast cars
you know being abusive and being a bully
etc etc these are signs of weakness of
insecurity and to be masculine should be
a sense of security and inner confidence
and Inner Strength right and that's what
we should venerate in our culture and we
should have icons like that okay um it
doesn't mean that that there's no role
for men who are not masculine or have
more of the feminine virtues that's also
there's definitely a role for that and
you know we see a lot of that in all
sorts of Arenas of life and then there
should be a positive model for women you
know where instead of their appearances
being judged by their appearances and
having to conform to ideals of what's
hot or not it's about being incredibly
powerful and comp ident and and have
expertise and being really successful in
your career and and as opposed to being
continually judged by your appearances
which is very damaging
so these are terrible times I mean I I
feel fortunate that I grew up in a time
where there were these kind of models
for me to go by and I think of my father
who who was a very quiet man and he was
he was just a middle class s salesman is
basically what he was he just sold for
all his whole life he sold chemical
supplies for one company um but he was
very dignified he treated people well he
was very calm and very quiet but he also
was very empathetic that was my role
model for what I think is a good
masculine energy and I think a lot of
people just don't have that and they're
very lost and so I don't know what the
answer is to that I can't really produce
that out of thin air but I wish I could
well certainly nowadays there are many
more um let's say examples and options
of masculine and feminine qualities out
there for observation because of social
media and because of the internet uh and
as you point out before a key feature to
becoming a functional human being
especially nowadays is learning what to
ignore I mean there's an interesting
idea in the circles around nutrition and
health that you know never before in
human history have human beings been
able to access such a wide variety of
foods that are differ from what their
ancestors ate and I don't even mean
ancient ancestors I mean if you grew up
in the Bay Area as I did in the 1970s
and 80s there were few ethnic
restaurants but we ate the same you know
15 or 20 Foods over and over again right
and then eventually that exploded into
dozens of options and more and fusion
foods and all sorts of things and so
there is this idea in the nutrition
communities that we are not hardwired to
um think about and discern so many
different food options that you know
that's um and to taste so many distinct
flavors whereas before people one
portion of the planet or country ate
generally one way in a given season if
there's seasonality etc etc in a similar
vein um we are now and children too are
now um overwhelmed with a number of
different options of how to express
oneself both masculinity and femininity
but generally speaking and so the
question is then how does one choose
right how does one decide what's what's
functional what works what's best what's
me right everyone asking themselves who
am I right I think all teenagers I find
this fascinating ask themselves who am I
adults don't tend to ask themselves that
question but who am I I still ask myself
question okay well that's good maybe I
should ask myself that more often but um
I think
that we clearly have gone over a cliff
with this stuff I don't think we're
still at the point where we're kind of
veering towards the edge of of confusion
I think young people are really confused
because the moment one assumes uh one
clear and let's say balanced Mas set of
masculine feminine attributes or maybe
ve a bit more masculine or a bit more
feminine it's like um there are a
million examples telling you that that's
wrong I know and then sometimes has the
tendency to Anchor to well no no I'm
right because this is this is who I am
and then all of a sudden you're you're
in a larger battle so uh you know Gary
Cooper's great love his movies um but
we're like we now have a million
variations on Gary Cooper um that don't
look anything like the Gary Cooper you
and I are talking about and a lot of
people won't even know who we're talking
about but I know
they I'm a dinosaur but perhaps it
illustrates the point no not that you're
a dinosaur but that um there is no
single or even um set of masculine or
feminine ideals so picking Role Models
is something that I really truly
internalized from your book Mastery yeah
you know I there were a lot of lonely
years for me and I won't get into the
stories of just wondering like my what
am I going to do you know I'm 13 my home
was completely broken no semblance of
the reality it was before you know who
are the the males in my life I'm going
to orient to and fortunately for me I
assigned mentors to me whether or not
they knew it or not that really helped
me along and I changed them up as you
recommend there wasn't one um I
understood there was a breaking up
process an integration process combined
ining and threading together different
things I think I truly believe that
that's what's required that um it
doesn't have to be 100% Gary Cooper it
can be 10% Robert Green 10% someone else
you know 5% this and creating a pie
chart of sorts of you know who one
wishes to be in a given context but that
takes work it takes a bit of work and
discernment but gosh that's powerful um
and really credit goes to you because I
you know you were a mentor of mine you
didn't even realize it in the way that
you forge and organize information and
there were others and but Mastery is
where I learned to do that and this is
not a podcast it's a a sales pitch for
Mastery but gosh it really taught me
okay I have a graduate adviser she was
wonderful and Brilliant but she didn't
know how to explain a lot of things to
me so I'd find someone else for that
right and someone else for the other
thing and someone else for the other
thing and together create a patchwork of
of really excellent mentors that made a
lot of sense to me yeah yeah so I I
think there's a a role for that process
that you spell out in Mastery in the
larger context of like could have become
as a person and that includes masculine
and feminine ideals yeah and and it's an
ongoing process throughout your life so
who you glommed on to when you were 14
or 15 will change when you're 19 I had a
series of people like you're talking
about my high school English teacher who
had an enormous impact on me who taught
me basically how to write I internalized
his voice when went to Berkeley I had a
professor there who became my kind of
surrogate father at Berkeley who I
deeply admired for his level of
scholarship so he became kind of an
intellectual role model later in life
when I finally wrote my first book I met
a man steers who was a book packager who
understood the business Etc he kind of
saved me he was sort of my mentor for
the next phase in my life so on and on
and on I found people but they have
positive qualities qualities they admire
they're not perfect everyone is
flawed and so at some point maybe you
see too many of the flaws you go on I
need somebody new in my life but there's
nothing wrong with that it's not like
you're you're you're violating any codes
or hurting them you move on to somebody
else but the sense of finding people
whose qualities you admire we don't
learn from people just by following
their ideas we pick up their energy
their Spirit now you didn't necessarily
pick up my energy or Spirit from Reading
Master although maybe you did I don't
know but when you're interacting with
that professor at Stanford or whatever
it's not just verbally there's kind of a
non-verbal communication going on you're
internalizing some of the positive
qualities that you saw in them and
finding these series of mentors because
I call it surrogate
parents you can't choose your father and
mother but you can choose these ideals
for you can choose these mentor towards
in your life you can kind of rewrite
your family history and find that Father
Figure You Never Had by glomming onto
this person but it has to be the right
fit it has to be someone that you
connect to emotionally and
intellectually and that has the positive
qualities you wish for yourself well
I'll embarrass you perhaps by saying
that um since I was a freshman in
college which is really when I turned my
academic life around and really my life
around I've maintained the same notebook
with a list of names of people that I
admire and who I'm um you know trying to
emulate in some way not in every way
certainly and certain names have been
crossed off but um most of them have
survived and and certainly after reading
Mastery your name made that list and um
and I hope I'm not being crossed off at
some point no not at all not not at all
and through Reading Mastery there were
there were additional names um you know
I had the great the great Misfortune of
having all three of my academic advisers
die suicide cancer cancer which sounds
tragic the the joke in my field is you
don't want me to work for you that's
what that's what everyone says but by
being essentially scientifically
orphaned because there's a strong Mentor
mentee relationship in science and
progression through the career uh track
it forced me to go out and find other
people and also to learn how to quote
unquote mother and father myself in the
context of profession and I got a lot of
help but um I I can't emphasize enough
how valuable that practice is and so
when one looks out on the landscape of
social media options I mean these are
literally just options of people to you
know we call it following but um you
know it probably should be called
something else uh because following you
know it fall short of emulating or
attempting to emulate but I think that
in the context of masculine and feminine
ideals this is so critical but it's like
the buffet of food is so enormous now
right I mean you've got every cuisine on
the table so we're we're not wired for
that no and I know personally I I get
very agitated and upset if I go to the
market and I have to choose between 30
items and I have no idea what I want it
makes me really cranky and upset whereas
if I know okay I can have this food I
can't have that I'm only looking for
this okay it's easy it doesn't take two
hours and waste my time too much choice
is very detrimental to the human being I
think and that's why going back to what
I originally said when you have that
sense of purpose about your life about
what's important it does just infects
your career but it infects every
everything you do so you know eating
this food is going to drain me of my
energy that I need to create this thing
that means so much to me and energy and
feeling my my brain active and alive is
incredibly important value all right I'm
not going to eat all that Sugar because
it's bad for me right it means I'm not
going to get outraged by these things on
the internet because it's a waste of
time I can't do anything about it it's
just feeding on my you know on my I
forget the part of the brain that's
that's like the amydala or whatever
right so no I don't want to go there
right and on and on and on all these
things in social media some of it's good
some of it's interesting I can follow
Andrew huberman's podcast and I enjoy
that and I learn a lot from it but a lot
of these podcasts are useless they're
they're not helping me in any way so it
gives you this kind of filter and this
radar to cut out those hundred different
choices that drive us absolutely crazy
and I know maybe I'm partially I maybe
I'm a little bit I don't know I hate to
say that maybe I'm partially on the
Spectrum or something but I can't trans
can't stand too many choices it
completely drives me nuts so I always
have to kind of funnel my energy into
something to things that are productive
and having a sense of your purpose
whenever you discovered in your 20s
hopefully gives you that ability to say
these are the positive role models I
want in my life these are the mentors
and the thing about following people on
social medas it's so easy it's just a
click it doesn't mean anything a mentor
relationship takes work it takes courage
because you have to actually go up to
somebody and physically ask for their
help and a lot of people write to me say
I'm afraid of asking this important
powerful person to be their mentee right
so it involves a sense of social courage
where you have to literally engage with
another human being who you admire and
who you think is powerful so it's
building your social skills Etc but it's
a skill you develop you can't just
follow someone you can't just watch
their lectures you have to engage with
them and you have to get over some of
your fears and your anxieties in the
process yeah and I might add to it uh I
think everything you say is absolutely
true and I think um engaging in the the
various um tools that they recommend is
immensely helpful like I think hear
hearing about a book is great reading a
book is even better um thinking about a
book is even that you read is even
better than that and then uh writing
down your own ideas and writing a book
well that's that's the big win right and
that's what the world I believe that's
what the universe wants from us not
necessarily to write a book but you know
translate what I just said to any number
of different Endeavors yeah you want to
be able to think for yourself right so
you're not just absorbing ideas from
other people and kind of mimicking them
and kind of just learning the exteriors
of their ideas you want to kind of
digest them and then have them slowly
become your own ideas by interacting
with them by creating and like putting
them through your own lens so someday
it's it's a book stirring in me is the
art of thinking and how to use that kind
of process and go deeper into it and I
talked a lot about it in one of my
podcasts which might be the seed of a
book but it's it's the the difference
between dead thinking and Alive thinking
ideas can be either alive or they can be
dead and an alive idea is something that
enters your brain from an external
Source a philosopher an article somebody
you admire somebody you hate and then
you absorb it and you think about it and
you decide I'm going to turn it around
into this and I'm going to make it alive
and it's going to make it something
that's part of me another part of an
alive idea is um you have an idea that
comes to you about a book or a project
or something about the world and you go
maybe that's not actually true maybe the
opposite is true and you go through a
process and you cycle through it on and
on and you reflect on it and you refine
this idea and maybe it turns into its
opposite and through the process of
reflecting and correcting and revising
it you turn it into something living
something alive within you right on and
on and on and what prevents people from
going through that process which would
be the subject of my book is basically
anxiety because I think how you handle
anxiety is the most important kind of
quality in life it'll determine whether
you will be successful whether you will
find your career path or whether you
won't be able to I don't know if you can
follow that idea at all but um anxiety
is a signal to you that you don't
understand something that that there's a
problem out there that that you can't
resolve and so what happen Happ s to
most people if you're insecure is you
glom onto something instant and easy to
get rid of your feeling of anxiety I
don't understand this problem oh it must
be a must a must be the answer because
this person said that right and so you
don't develop the the ability to think
you don't Dev the ability to go to the
next level but if you take that anxiety
and you go all right maybe a is an
answer and then you start going through
a and then you go no maybe a isn't the
answer maybe B is the answer you're able
to surmount your anxiety and go past it
further and further and further you
don't rush for the first available
answer that's out there right you're
able to go through a process of refining
things and so in your
career if you're anxious for Success if
you're anxious for money you're going to
make the wrong choices but if you're
able to deal with that anxiety and say
maybe I'm I have to think more deeply
about where I'm going I have to come up
with other alternatives then you're
going to make a much better choice on
and on and on so how if you're deal if
you're a creative person it's very very
challenging to have that blank piece of
paper before you that book that you
haven't written that film or whatever
you're filled with a lot of anxiety and
you have to deal with it and if you're
able to turn into something creative and
productive then great things will happen
you'll create a masterpiece so the
ability to deal with anxiety and to not
give into the most instant gratification
that you can get is to me a marker of
somebody who will be creative and will
invent something as opposed to people
who just recycle old and dead
ideas Amen to that I uh was once told
that you know anxiety makes children of
us all and not in the positive sense of
being childlike you know it it regresses
us to a mode where we feel a complete
lack of control and I completely agree
that being able to manage anxiety and
and work dance with it yeah since we
can't rid ourselves of it no perhaps nor
should we right because it's a signal as
you point out that we don't understand
something that there's there's something
to get curious about right a process or
something out there or both I think uh
that really resonates yeah and I think a
lot of people will benefit from from
hearing that because I think we hear the
word flow and we just all imagine I even
catch myself imagining that you know
when Robert Green sits down to right
it's like there's a blank sheet and then
he just kind of meditates and then boom
out com these books um but I you know if
I get realistic for a second I'm sure
that there's a lot of inner turmoil and
anxiety my God you have no idea so um my
process is is 95% pain and maybe 2 and a
half% ecstasy and I don't know what the
other two and a half% would be but um so
I write a story because all in my new
book and most of my books I always begin
with the story from history
Etc and it is so bad it I just I can't
believe how bad how flat it is how it
sucks I'm so embarrassed I hate myself
then I go and I go dig into and I start
changing the words in it I start making
a little bit better the second version
It's kind of palatable but it still
sucks it's if I let it out the world it'
be very embarrassing I work I it's an
anxious you know and my wife can tell
you I'm a miserable being when that
happens everything looks black to me at
that point and and I pushed through it
so if I gave in to my anxiety and this
happens with a lot of books and writers
I would just put out that second version
which isn't very good it isn't very
strong it isn't thought through because
my ideas when I look at them the first
time I go that's not real that's not the
actual thing that's going on here Robert
you've missed the mark you want to hit
what's actually real in that story so
you have to go deeper and deeper and
harder and harder and harder so I don't
just give up and go here's the chapter I
go it's got to be better it's got to be
better until
finally after two months of
struggling it seems like it's it's gone
to the place that I want it to be in
right but I I use that anxiety to keep
improving and making it better and then
when I reach that point and the story is
good enough and I can let my wife read
it and then my editor I feel great I
have that 2% moment of Joy but it came
through all of that anxiety but I can
can tell you the feeling of fulfillment
when I finish a chapter is pretty damn
great when I finish a
book it's better than any kind of drug
experience anyone could ever have it's
such a wonderful feeling of
accomplishment and pushing past all the
barriers you know so my process involves
a lot of anxiety and dealing with that's
why I'm talking about it why I want to
write a book about it thank you for
sharing that um I'm attempting to write
a book and have been for several years
and now I feel a little bit better but
clearly I need to ratchet down harder um
but in other domains of life I I am
familiar with the experience of tons of
anxiety and just okay I'm going to just
get to this one Milestone and then I'll
figure out the next Milestone but even
that process of saying okay I'm going to
break this down into Milestones itself
is anxiety provoking it's just that but
at some point it generates enough
inertia that you just that you just sort
of stumble forward into the process and
then keep going so try not to bloody
oneself that's right too much yeah I
think a lot of people will benefit from
hearing about that in fact I'm certain
they will So speaking of anxiety you
have a clip on the internet that we will
provide a link to in the show note
captions which I think is absolutely
fabulous about how to find a romantic
partner and or get more out of an
existing romantic partnership I don't
even remember what I said you're gonna
have to remind me oh it's so good
um
one point in particular yeah that uh I
remember um that I think is oh so true
is that there needs to be at least one
and probably several uh points of like
real convergence in terms of one's
interests or likes that go beyond like
what food somebody likes or uh you know
what type of house they want to live in
but that actually traces back to these
early form forms of delight and you
mentioned uh that for you and therefore
presumably your partner that you know a
mutual love and respect for Animals
happens to be one of those things within
the context of your relationship right
that not that A Love For Animals is
required for me it sure as hell is right
exactly I could never go out with a
woman who didn't love animals right my
sister used to tease me that um if a
woman gave me a birthday card or a card
that had a drawing of a particular
animal which I'm particularly fond of my
sister used I have an older sister and
she used to say oh no it's over he's
gone you know that it would you know um
fortunately it's it's not that simple um
but uh there's some truth to what she
was saying um it's certainly uh it's
necessary but not sufficient but maybe
you could elaborate a little bit on this
notion of um convergent interest and
contrast it with a lot of what people
tend to hear and say about what's
important in Partnership
because I think this is something that a
lot of people grapple with both in terms
of finding a partner and in terms of
building
partnership well um you have to you know
there's you can there's different
relationships you can have I mean do you
want like a one week a one month
relationship or you looking for
something longer more satisfying that
will entail you know maybe years of
being
together and um you know uh people can
get very boring very quickly right
particularly if you can't have a
conversation with them about subjects
that interest you and so you mention
animals animals is a very good example
because it's not I'm not saying that you
both have to be Democrats or Republicans
that's too banal and superficial but the
Love of Animals reaches into your
character reaches something deep inside
of you or your dislike of animals if
that happens to be the case but it
signals something about it that's so
Primal that's so connected to a
child that there's going to be a deep
connection there and it's not like you
have to both love cats which is good if
that happens to be the case but just
animals in general you love their energy
you love the fact that they're that
they're innocent in their own way you
love the fact that they're not playing
games with you you love the kind of
instant love you can get from them kind
of thing and you connect to them on that
level is a very very positive sign
because it goes beyond just intell ual
things into something emotional and
visceral so really the emotional
connections the values that you have
together are very important money is
another one that's extremely important
so if one of you is incredibly material
oriented and it's all about money is is
is power and success and comfort and the
other isn't really into it it's into
spending money Etc a lot of people have
endless fights or something like money
right where there's no convergence there
and money signals a deeper value about
the person so I'm not saying there's
anything wrong if money motivates you
I'm not moralizing about it because that
can signal a value that maybe you grew
up without it and that feeling
comfortable and feeling like you don't
have to worry about something is very
very important to you and the not being
interested in money reveals something
about your character so I'm telling
people you want to look at the person's
character and see a kind of convergence
there and something that can last and I
remember I was reading um for one of my
books about Franklin delanor Roosevelt
and Elanor Roosevelt and the thing of it
was Franklin delanor Roosevelt was his
incredibly handsome vibrant young man
before he got polio very active very
athletic very handsome all the women
were after him he was like the perfect
match he was wealthy and Elanor
Roosevelt was like the ugly duckling she
she wasn't very pretty she was kind of
socially
awkward but he saw into her character he
saw that intellectually she was a match
for him he saw that they had kind of
similar interests on that level that I'm
talking about that go beneath just the
surfaces and he chose Elanor and
everyone was shocked about it you know
nobody was was trying to court Elanor
I've WR her last name at the time I
think she might have even be a Roosevelt
um so it was very shocking you said I I
looked at somebody who I could last with
who had some qualities that were much
more important to me and it ended up
being a very satisfying relationship of
course later on he had his Dianes so it
wasn't perfect but it was a very it was
a very positive relationship so seeing
your values in life you know when it
comes to like money when it comes to
like career when it comes to comfort or
lack of comfort some people like like
not being comfortable they like being on
the edge they want challenges they want
to move from City to City kind of thing
and if you partner with somebody who
just wants to live in the same house
you're going to have conflict after
conflict after conflict the sex might be
great and that might be good for a month
or two months I have nothing against
that I'm not going to judge that either
but it won't lead to a longlasting
relationship you know Sports and
Athletics are another thing is this
someone that likes the outdoors or is it
someone who's you know like zaha Gabor
has to be in in a Time Square in a
penthouse in Manhattan you know kind of
thing so values that reach inside of a
per character that are deeply ingrained
that you can almost not change you can't
control and there's a convergence there
on several levels is a sign that you can
have a deep connection with that person
and it's very important and if those
connections are good and there's a
physical attraction because if without
the physical attraction it will kind of
fizzle out you've got a recipe for for
incredible success for something that
can really last and having a lasting
relationship as I've
had is is such an anchor in your life
you know for me for someone who works as
hard as I do and hopefully for her as
well it just grounds me and it makes
life so much simpler and easier and and
it's not just simple and easy there's a
lot of love and a great deal of of
of deeper emotions involved but having a
long-term relationship if you can have
it is something that pays off in so many
dividends so being able to find that
kind of convergence you know when I
first met my now my wife um I had a cat
at the time I'd always been a dog person
but this was a cat I had and I love that
cat like hell I can't believe he was
such a wonderful
cat I brought her over to my apartment
on the first date I wanted to see her
reaction to the cat you know cuz I
generally and I don't know people
misjudge that women who don't like cats
I I don't I can't get along with right
because there's something feline in the
feminine nature that I love and she
loved my cat boy that was the best sign
of all and things just Bloss and she
loved me for loving a cat so there was a
great convergence right there that we
saw right away and there were other
things but that was the first one
I love that story and everything you
just said suggests I believe that in
order to
find the right partner and to build an
existing partnership that hopefully
feels at least partially right to people
that it requires at least some knowing
of self Because unless you know your
character one's own character then it's
impossible to really determine if
somebody else's character is going to
mesh well with it or not self awareness
is is actually the most important
quality in life for all aspects but yeah
I mean if we go by social pressures a
man will choose a trophy wife who looks
sexy and hot and will impress all of his
male friends etc etc you go by the
things that culture tells you that these
are the right images for you right and
then there won't be any connection to
you because you're choosing for purposes
that don't connect to who you are and so
you have to know yourself you have to
know what you love you have to know what
you hate I think most people know that
they love animals or don't love animals
I think most people know that they like
stability or they like things to be kind
of slightly chaotic I don't think you
have to go through deep levels of
introspection but what you have to do is
when you're involved in a relationship
you have to think that those things
matter that's the problem you tend to
think that those things may you think
that sex matters more than anything
physical attraction matters or you think
that the person having a lot of money
matters etc etc you don't think that
this other aspect is important if you
value what I'm talking about then your
self-awareness will kick in because you
really basically know these essential
basic parts about your own character I
think people sometimes get um distracted
by admiration of qualities that they
might
find
admirable but that don't mesh with their
own character I've seen this many times
before where well uh where someone will
say well there someone will start
listing off the positive attributes of
the person that they happen to be dating
like he does this blank blank and blank
she does this you know he volunteers Etc
and that's all great I mean volunteering
for good causes I'm all in support of
that but then what they're overlooking
often it seems is whether or not that's
a core value for them or whether or not
it's just something that they admire I
hear a lot of admiration in the early
days of relationships that later I hear
about failing and what you're talking
about is something deeper more uh
aligned with one's own sense of self and
it almost um leads me to use the word
you know sort of a more about energetics
it's like merging of people's energies
which sounds very new Agy and that's not
my intention but but I think it relates
to something that we do hear a lot about
and I think is valid which is how it
feels to be around somebody in different
context like do we feel at ease do we
feel lightness an ability to express
ourselves and to um and do we enjoy and
admire them in their expression as
opposed to just admiring what they do
they've accomplished blank blank and
blank I see right they uh manifest these
qualities that I wish I had right you
hear that and and aspire to have which
is very different than a meshing of of
energies also there a couple other
things you have to understand their
character as well and people can be very
deceptive and very slippery and can wear
masks one telling sign that I've noticed
in my own relationships in the
past is that the woman would be a
certain way with me that I thought was
very good and I liked and then the
moment we were with other people she
acted in a way that was very irritating
it's like a different character and I
really kind of fell out of love with her
when I saw her in social interactions
she revealed so with me she was almost
wearing a mask and playing a game but
the moment she entered a different
circumstance I saw another aspect to her
character so you also have to be very
attentive to their character what lies
underneath that they have some of these
values that they're not just trying to
win you over for whatever and they're
playing along with you the other thing
that's very
important is a sense of mystery so a
partner can become boring very very
quickly right after a year you know
every single thing about them right
they're going to say the same things the
conversations go around in circles it's
just you've reached an end there's no
surprises there's no mystery you want
somebody where they have corners that
you don't really see at first that they
surprise you sometimes suddenly there's
a quality that you hadn't suspected
before so people who are too obvious who
are too familiar who show everything
instantly they're going to end up boring
you right but people who have a bit of
Reserve I I know this is maybe I'm I'm
projecting my own values on the world
but people who who kind of intrigue you
that you don't fully understand that
make you want to know more and if they
can be like that after two years or
three years or five years wow that's
fantastic but the sense of I know every
single thing about this person they
never surprise me anymore is what kind
of breaks the the the enchantment and
leads to the end of the relationship
well the idea of more to learn about
somebody
um perhaps also suggests that they are
continuing to evolve into forage in the
landscape of life you know that they're
not fully baked yeah right that which I
think is um an interesting idea in
during the four episode series that we
did on Mental Health Paul kti a
psychiatrist said that um a matching of
generative drives which he defined as
the desire to create something in the
world of One's Own expression is really
critical in relationship and he said you
know it matters less whether or not one
person likes classical music and the
other person rock and roll provided that
their relationship to music is similar
or something of that sort like that it's
about a drive to of a certain sort to
engage in the world so one person could
love music the other person's not into
music but the way that they approach
life is one of perhaps Mutual curiosity
desire to find out Etc and that this
exists on a Continuum uh I'm curious if
uh it seems to jive with what you're
with what you're saying it does but the
only thing I would add is
if you love classical music and they
love like heavy metal music you're going
to be driven crazy pretty quickly it's
going to you know it's not going to mesh
with you and I know I would have that
problem you'll both be in headphones a
lot right so the fact that you both have
because music is like animals in a way
so I agree completely with what you're
saying but I would say maybe music isn't
the best example because music says
something very deep about a person right
there and you know I'm not saying one is
superior to the other but it reveals
something that's nonverbal that that
kind of gives you a window into who they
are so if they like punk rock like you
do and I grew up on punk rock there's a
rebellious thing this to there's an
anti-authoritarian quality that's very
strong you get you get to see that
through them if they like modart and
soft string quartets there's somebody
that kind of value softness and
tranquility and peace and you're not
like that so the music kind of shows you
something a quality about their
character that can be very telling and
be very eloquent and so it doesn't mean
that you both have to love The Clash or
the dead kennedies or whatever showing
my own Generation Um but that you both
have that rebellious streak and that
rebellious streak could be you like
there's classical music composers who
could be pretty damn rebellious and
angry you know and I actually kind of
like them so that convergence I think is
a positive one kind of thing but in
general I agree with that I'm curious
about the non-verbal communication
component of all types of relationships
but let's stay in the landscape of
romantic relationships for the moment
yeah maybe include professional
relationships too because what you just
described is really about a resonance
around the non-verbal stuff I mean it
can be articulated with words yeah um I
love animals I love this music this is
the best song like did you see that like
otter are amazing right this kind of
thing but language is just an attempt to
place you know words on a Feeling in
those instances so it it can be
classified as non-verbal
um with respect to non-verbal
communication you've
written fairly extensively about the
fact that people often communicate with
their body and facial
expressions um uh I'm certainly familiar
with the somewhat if not very eerie
sensation of somebody um smiling like a
toothy smile and then it as they pivot
away that smile just dissolving very
quickly and um you know you don't have
to be a neuroscientist or a psychologist
to realize that like there was something
quite false about that experience or
that this person experiences um emotions
like step functions on off on off which
is not how most of us EXP experience
emotions most of us experience emotions
with some pervasiveness like I was happy
walking in the door because of something
happened before and so I'm going to
smile while I'm walking in the door if I
see something shocking and dismaying of
course I'm going to frown I'm going to
wipe away that smile but those are rare
instances so um let's talk about the
mouth the eyes the face the body in the
context of communication what are what
are some important things to pay
attention that I I I I want to go back
on as far as convergence is sense of
humor is extremely important right so
it's not like you both like the same
comedians but if one person likes ranchy
humor and the other person doesn't
that's that's a problem and also the
fact that the person doesn't have a
sense of humor or doesn't make you laugh
is a very very bad sign so I wanted to
add that one component in there I'm so
glad you did uh someone who can make me
laugh has uh you know necessary but not
sufficient but boy it's uh approaching
sufficient yeah I'd say so I'd say so um
you know when it comes to the Art of
Seduction The Art of Seduction is a
nonverbal language that you must Master
it's a language of the gifts that you
give it's a ma it's a language of of how
you smell it's a language that you TR
that you communicate through the eyes
etc etc and the thing you have to
understand about the human being is that
we evolved for much longer period of
time without words than the small 40
35,000 years that we have symbolic
language so during that vast period of
Darkness where we did not have words we
were non communicating non-verbally we
were picking up signals from people we
were watching every little detail of
their behavior because we didn't have
words to decipher it so it's wired into
our brains to have an amazing
sensitivity to people's non-verbal
Communications we can almost be
telepathic that way if we learn that
language the problem is we have the
capacity but we don't develop it at all
because we are so word oriented you're
just listening to people if you're even
listening to them at all you're just
hearing the words and you're so thinking
that the words mean something the words
are sincere which they're often not at
the same time that you're listening so
much to words people are shuffling in
their chair they're kind of looking away
they're looking at other women or other
men their voice is kind of trembling
when they say something that where it
shouldn't tremble their eyes are dead
the smile is kind of fake you're not
watching any of it so the most important
thing in non-verbal communication law
number one is pay attention to it
continually develop the practice of
shutting off the words and watching
people almost as if you took the
television and muted it right and just
watched their behavior it's not easy and
it's not natural because it's the words
the words were words we want to we want
to focus on them right but your ability
to turn that television off to mute it
will suddenly open up so many things
about people they reveal so much things
Sigman Freud said people are continually
oozing out all of their secrets through
their non-verbal Behavior you can read
them like an open book if you master
this language and I have in the laws of
human nature I describe the story of
Milton Ericson I don't know if you're
familiar with Milton ericsen perhaps the
greatest modern master of non-verbal
communication he was a an amazing
psychologist he sort of um is the
inspiration behind um n what's it called
n help me out here neuro linguistic oh
the NLP I it's kind of a bastardization
of his ideas but he's he created
hypnotherapy he's the person who created
hypnotherapy certainly I uh hypnotherapy
is is a valid psychiatric practice I
mean it's excellent clinical data to
support well Milton Ericson had Polio
when he was 19
and he was paralyzed his entire body was
paralyzed he couldn't even move his
eyeballs right and he sat in bed and he
had a very active mind and he was going
to just die from sheer boredom and what
he did during the two years of being
paralyzed like that was just watching
People's non-verbal communication and
making notes in his brain and learning
every single he learned the 20 different
forms of yes the 100 different forms of
no right every intonation how somebody
entered the room how they left the room
you know how they looked at him with the
pity or empathy or something he mastered
it and then when he became a
psychiatrist and he treated people they
thought he was psychic he could see
everything into them it's because for
two years that's all he could do was
Observe them he couldn't speak he
couldn't do anything he couldn't read a
book so you have that same power but you
don't have po obviously but you have to
first pay attention to it right it's an
amazing thing once you do it's a lot of
fun actually and I tell people go to a
cafe one day in your city wherever you
live and just watch people because you
can't hear them they're a few tables
away watch their non-verbal Behavior as
they interact and see if if you pick up
cues from them and there are things that
are signs of genuine emotions so for
instance an exercise you can do is you
go up to somebody from an angle where
they can't see you coming up to them and
you surprise them you go hey hey Mike
whatever they turn for that second their
expression reveals how they really think
about you you'll detect if you can pick
up micro expressions and and you can
they're only like one 150th of a second
but they're there you can express a kind
of and they smile you can see the little
disdain in their eyes right then the
mask comes on right or you're talking to
them they're looking at you but their
feet are facing in an opposite direction
that means that they're dying to get
away from you kind of thing these are
signals that you don't necessarily pay
attention to their posture will tell you
everything about their levels of
confidence right on and on and on the
fake smile if you can just Master the
ability to detect the fake smile it will
go wonders for you because you're able
to see what you really want to do is to
see the person with a genuine smile
particularly in romantic
relationships someone whose face lights
up a real smile lights your whole face
up it doesn't light your mouth that
these parts of your face go up your eyes
get alive there's like a there's like a
a neuro thing going on in your brain
that's changing your whole facial
expression and it means that someone
genuinely likes you they're genuinely
interested in you they're genuinely
laughing or connecting to you man if you
can see that it'll help you so much in
the Romantic realm and that'll help you
get away from those toxic people that
are continually faking interest in you
because a narcissist a toxic
person thrives by deceiving you with a
Charming alluring front that makes you
come into their world then they can hurt
you then they can do something to you
right then they have you in in in their
in their you know in their trap right so
being able to see that they're not
genuinely interested in you that they're
faking it will help you avoid very toxic
relationships and as I said to you I
don't know if we were on air or not but
deep narcissists have dead eyes they
they almost can't help it they can fake
the smile they can fake everything else
but the eyes you have to be able to read
it because you say well what are dead
eyes you'll know it when you see it
there's no life in them they're like
looking through you they're not looking
at you they're looking through you what
can I get out of you you're what they
call a selfobject they're an object for
you to use and that's how they're
looking at you like they would look at a
hammer or something yeah the concept of
dead eyes
and also alive eyes is so fascinating
because um as audience of this podcast
will know that because I've said it too
much but I'll say it again that the eyes
are the only two pieces of your brain
that are outside the cranial Vault I
mean they're literally two pieces of
brain linning the back of your eyes and
the Dynamics of the pupils those changes
of course reflect how bright or dim it
is in the room but they also reflect
levels of arousal that are on the
millisecond time scale so as one
expresses you know words of um of Glee
right the pupils constrict a little bit
believe it or not or excuse me dilate a
little bit I got it backwards there for
a moment um and vice versa you know as
one feels uh less less excited um sort
of moments of Despair expressions of
Despair that people should get a little
bit smaller because arousal is going
down and so I think you know we pick up
on these things at a unconscious level
we do um the deadness of the eyes is is
kind of the the um the the conclusion
that that pops out at us if we're paying
attention but the problem is it love it
registers unconsciously but we don't
give it any value to it we trust our
words we trust our rationality as
opposed to our intuitions about people
so sometimes when you meet a person for
the first time signals go up in your
mind brain something's wrong about them
and then you forget it because you don't
trust those initial unconscious signals
that your brain is giving you right so
you have to you have to first kind of
trust that this that these intuitions
are very valuable the other thing is pay
deep attention to the tone of voice The
Voice as actors will tell you is like
the hardest thing to fake right it's
very hard to fake excitement your voice
either has it or it doesn't it's very
hard to fake confidence and you can I
mean books have been written about that
I'm not going to go into all the the
details about it but the person will
reveal so much of their emotional of the
emotions that they're experiencing
particularly levels of confidence you
know like a trembling Voice or something
or a booming confident voice which some
people can fake but often it's very
difficult you can still see through it
and on the level of
Seduction women men are very very
attuned to the voice of a woman but
we're not aware of it because the voice
of our mother had an incredible impact
on us in early early early childhood her
singing her the tone of her voice that
was probably the first seduction that we
ever went through and a woman's voice
has tremendous power over us right and
so hearing a voice that kind of great
Ates or irritates you is is something
that's that's a bad sign and that goes
deeper than all the characteristics that
we were talking about but a woman's
voice that kind of reminds you of that
mother that sing songy whatever feeling
it was that's that's somebody that's
that can very easily seduce you yeah
there's a um there's a place for uh
naming this of it's like subcortical
courtship uh you know you know below the
cortex as the geeky neuroscientists like
myself say you know you're getting down
below the cortex with all of this stuff
you know convergence of of real uh loves
and desires I mean we express with words
we sense the world using of course our
cortex but we're really talking about
getting into the the subcortical stuff
that is the stuff of our history the
stuff of our um hardwiring and our
unique our uniqueness I couldn't help
but think about the fact that earlier we
were talking about the now you know
infinitely vast number of choices of
things to engage in people to engage
with Etc
but at the same time as you were now
talking about um these micro inflections
and the subtleties of voice and bodily
communication that whether or not it's
emojis or people sending filtered images
or the default to text message
communication that is so prominent now
it seems like we now have more choices
so uh more input
but the sort of qualitative differences
between the puts have been binned into a
couple of simple bins as if it's as if
we've um regressed to primary colors
only um but the canvas is huge or may I
don't know if that analogy works but you
you get the idea because ultimately in
order to develop good choices about
profession romantic relationships
friendships you need a lot of examples
and a lot of information that allows you
to glean the subtlety um but as long as
it's emojis and filtered pictures taken
at a particular angle angle you know
usually from above ask for the picture
headon and Below send me a picture of
your worst your worst expression um all
of that um it seems that there's now
increased opportunity for deception and
I don't just mean people misleading
others I also mean us misleading
ourselves like oh my goodness how could
I be so disappointed yet again about
particular landscape of life it doesn't
just have to be romantic interactions it
could be other Landscapes like how could
I be fooled well you're fooled because
the the uh the inputs were deficient not
good data as we say well the thing is if
things are are you're immersed in the
virtual
realm it's very very hard to master the
non-verbal communication aspect which is
so important so if you're dating from an
app and you're flipping through and then
you find that person you've missed out
on the greatest experience of life which
is actually having to to go out to a bar
or go to a restaurant or go to a social
event and have to literally encounter
another person and deal with looking at
their their behavior and kind of
assessing who they are it's a muscle
that you have to pay attention to
non-verbal communication and if you're
just you know going through the Emojis
or going through the Tinder apps that
muscle completely atrophies you have no
power you're not able to decipher
anything and that's what's happening
with a lot of people who are using these
apps a social skills are like any skill
at all they you have to develop them
it's a muscle you have to develop and
you've all noticed this probably in your
own life if you've gone through a period
where you're kind of retreating you
don't want to be around people and you
spend a month like that and then you go
out you feel awkward it takes you like a
couple days to get used to being around
other people you say stupid things your
body language is awkward but if you're
in a situation for months where you're
constantly interacting people you're on
a film set and day in day out day out
that skill starts developing but you
have to be out there in the world you
have to be interacting you have to be
looking at people's emotions you have to
be gauging them in real time we're not
built for virtual encounters we're
creatures of human of Flesh and Blood
and we need to be looking at each other
in the eye and paying attention to all
these little details these new nuances
that you can only get in person along
those lines what are your thoughts about
Ai and how that's going to shape our um
sense of self sense of others and
relationships as if that's a topic that
could be covered in uh a series of
minutes but what what are your um what
are your top Contour maybe even deeper
thoughts about AI well I'm gonna I'm
going to piss a lot of people off but
I'm I'm kind of very concerned about it
um I mentioned before about anxiety the
role that anxiety plays in thinking you
come upon an
idea and you go yeah that's all good
then you go to the next level and it
becomes better and you go oh maybe
that's not so good then you go to the
next level you go to level three and it
gets better and better you have anxiety
another aspect of intelligence is
self-awareness right the beity to look
at yourself go I have biases I have
confirmation bias I have conviction bias
I have recency bias I have to counteract
these things I also have a dark side I
have aggression I have to be aware of
how they color my thinking my emotions
the third quality that goes into int I'm
talking about now intelligence not
artificial intelligence is the beity to
deal anxiety and go to a third level
intelligence is the ability to look
inside of yourself and see your own
biases and the third thing is the
ability to see a holistic picture the
kind of aha moment that scientists have
where you accumulate all kind of data
points and then out of nowhere an image
comes to your mind of yeah there's the
answer you see the whole thing you see
the whole Gestalt right Simone vile
compared it to a a um a square Cube you
can only see a cube from one side or you
can never see a a square Cube you can
only see a side of it if it's rotating
you're still only seeing sides of it
only in your mind can you picture the
whole thing so the mind has to go
through a process to have holistic
thinking if they can invent a machine
machine that can deal with anxiety and
has anxiety and can go to level three if
they can make a machine that can be
self-aware that can go the people who
program me have biases therefore I have
biases I also have a dark side because
people have program you have a dark side
if this machine can also think
holistically beyond all of the data
points and all the massive information
it's combined it can have that aha
moment all right I can see a human
consciousness I can see creativity there
the other thing I would say is when I
was a student at Berkeley going way back
I was 19 years old I decided One Summer
this is a big paradigm shift for me I'm
going to take this class in ancient
Greek in six weeks they teach you a year
of ancient Greek that means every day
you have an exam every Friday you have a
final exam eight hours every day of a
dead language I thought this would be
the best discipline for me after someone
who didn't been doing too many drugs to
be honest with you okay and so finally
at one point they give us this paragraph
of the hardest ancient Greek writer of
all to read this was near the end
thiddies or thiddies as they
say I st so I had I had like the whole
night to try and translate one paragraph
I couldn't figure it out you have to
understand the the weirdness of ancient
Creek all the endings the weird ways of
thinking the whole picture that aha
moment was luding me at one point I
thought I got it and I translated it and
I gave it to the teacher next day I
remember he was this kind of hippie that
you'd have it Berkeley Dennis classic
Professor but also hippie the fact that
you knew his first name is very tell I
can only remember his first name Dennis
he he's he said Robert I can see your
thinking but you need to go to another
level you missed you didn't have that
aha moment you didn't put the whole
thing together you were close but you
didn't you have to try harder and that
stuck in my mind forever like whenever I
have a problem I have to think harder I
have to go to that next level now what
would happen if I had pulled out my
translation of through cities and just
copied that out right or what have
happened if I put it through chat GPT
and it gave me the translation that
muscle in my brain that I have developed
for 40 years that allows me to write
books would never have developed and
that muscle is I don't know the answer
here I have to go to another level I
have to try harder I have to think I
have have to think I have to have that
engine worring around right but if I
just grab for chat GPT it's deadened and
then we're going to have a whole
generation of people who stop thinking
who don't go through that process you
know you've heard of Douglas Heder I
think he said people train to go to
Mount Everest it takes months physical
exertion it's painful then they climb
Mount Everest they see the top whoow
what a great moment he said Chad GPT be
the equivalent of taking a helicopter to
the top of Mount Everest without any of
that training and having the same moment
it's not the same right you need to go
through that process you need to go
through that pain and if you just and
the thing of is Chad gbt we think we're
so modern So Sophisticated but really
we're just seduced by Magic you put it
in there and you see the scri
going whoa It's like magic it's like a
magician but it's empty it's like not
your brain functioning right it's pay
it's the Pagan part of us we like that
kind of
magic as opposed to actually having to
go through the thought process itself so
I'm not in FA against having tools I use
tools I use the internet I use Google
I'm searching for like some factoid from
my book I find it I use it I I like it
but I've also learned to develop my
brain to think to get that engine
constantly moving and I'm deeply
concerned about people who can't learn a
foreign language who can't master
anything who just immediately grab the
first answer that it generates etc etc I
have
concerns I am too and I was thinking a
moment ago that you know like some
people might hear what you just said and
say oh well the same thing was probably
said about the automobile like how many
amazing experiences of walking from one
place to another are going to be lost
when people start driving from one place
to another but I think a key difference
and this certainly aligns with
everything you just said is that what
you're talking about is not just
arriving at the same destination you're
saying the destination itself is
different when one exerts some effort
and experiences some anxiety to get
there so it's not the same as automobile
versus horse versus walking versus
airplane yeah it's fundamentally
different because the the journey
transforms the outcome yeah yeah I I'm
in agreement with you about many aspects
of AI I'm also excited about it in the
context of certain things I I I I agree
with you if could be a tool but are we
operating the tool or is the tool
operating us is what I'm talking about I
am concerned a bit too especially in the
context of what we've been talking about
for most of today's discussion about um
avatars replacing our online personas
too much um you know the
Avatar of ourselves is already taking
place through through filters through uh
reduction of emotional expression to
emojis through reduction of of language
to a diminish number of words to explain
one's feelings you know a prior guest on
this podcast um Lisa Feldman Barrett
who's an expert in emotions talked about
how the moment that a culture has a word
for a particular subset of anxious
feelings so so for instance she taught
me that in Japanese there's a word for
the sadness one experiences when they
get a bad haircut yeah I know you know
and so that normalizes the feeling and
leads to feelings of less despair as
opposed to what now many kids especially
grow up learning which I'm anxious I'm
sad I'm depressed that you know in
science we say there are lumpers and
there are Splitters and they've been
arguing for years about like is that one
brain structure well if I name those two
things next to each other two different
things not only can I name one after
myself which is what tends to happen so
to speak but when you have too many
lumpers or too many Splitters things are
either overly simple or overly complex
that of course the right answer the the
the best use of naming things arrive
someplace in the middle right that's how
a field progresses because if you if you
lump things together too much a field
can't progress you give yourself the
illusion that it's progressing but it's
not progressing but if you split things
up into a million different
subcategories like just even the word
adrenaline is also called epinephrine
and that's has to do with basically
people arguing over who got credit crazy
and it's confused people for for decades
yeah and there's a there's another story
there that and I know far too much about
the scientists involved and the there
was a love triangle about naming of
certain parts of the nervous system oh
yeah people sleeping with other people's
partners and love triangles have have
created more drama of gnomen clature in
science I I could do a whole hour on
this um in any case I what I'm hearing
from you is that we cannot afford to
lose our sense of nuance and also
because that sense of nuance Taps into
what we're really experiencing and AI
threatens that that we can become
avatars of oursel well look at it this
way we we worship technology it's our
new religion okay and we worship chap
GPT as if it's a God I'm seriously
there's religious elements going on here
what we really should worship is the
human brain which is the greatest
creation in the known universe I'm
afraid it is the most complex piece of
matter in the entire universe the number
of neurons the number of synapses the
number of possible connections between
neurons is infinite practically infinite
it is a wondrous instrument it is so
powerful we've we've barely scratched
the surface of what we can use for it
let us worship that brain that's in your
head you only have so many years to use
it you have so many years to develop it
it is so wonderful and Powerful that can
bring you such pleasure so much power in
life so tools are fine we all need tools
we all need we need hammers we need
Nails we need saws Etc but the real
thing is the hand that uses it the brain
that connects the hand to the Hammers
that knows how to to hit things you know
I think of the of the um the great
painter Renoir in the 19 century he had
like a a stroke or something then the
last years he couldn't move his right
arm which with she painted with and it
was disastrous so what he did is he put
the brush in his mouth and he painted
and he painted some beautiful paintings
that way because his brain had mastered
the art of painting not his hand but his
brain had mastered it so well that he
could actually paint well with the brush
in his mouth because he could direct it
and he could he had the knowledge of how
to make something perfect the brain is
absolutely incredible the plasticity of
the brain which I'm discovering after my
stroke is absolutely a miracle you know
what I don't know is it Professor
Schwarz at UCLA who was studying OCD and
how he was able to kind of cure people
of OCD through certain plasticity
exercises that he had making them aware
of their kind of brain lock Etc and
getting them out of it the that
plasticity of the brain is by far the
greatest Miracle of all and it goes on
until your 60s and 70s and on onward
let's all get down on our hands and
knees and worship the brain and if we
did it would create a complete shift in
our values and we wouldn't be so
instantly seduced and enamored and
worshiping the technology we would
worship the brains that create the
technology instead of you know the other
way around we certainly got a fan of
brains and their uh potential for
plasticity sitting over here uh I have
the benefit of having my scientific
great-grandparents are hu weel who won
the Nobel Prize for neuroplasticity
during the critical period say that
again so my scientific great-
grandparents are David hubel and toron
visel David's dead Ton's still alive
he's 96 and they won the Nobel Prize for
essentially discovering the critical
window early in development where
plasticity is especially robust they did
other things too they should have won
two nobels frankly uh for their other
work on Vision but um one thing that
they missed however was something that
you mentioned and is worth uh
highlighting again which is that the
brain maintains the capacity for immense
plasticity throughout the entire
lifespan that's absolutely clear the
conditions change from early to later in
life but your specific situation really
highlights and it's something I'd really
like to um talk about for a few minutes
if if you're willing um as you mentioned
you experienced a stroke um and perhaps
uh it was aware to some but perhaps not
to all especially the people just
listening to this podcast and who are
not watching on video that um your shirt
while very nicely designed um in uh in
its original state also includes some
unique stitching so maybe you could
share with us uh what and for those
listening there's a there's a jagged
line of stitching that um extends from
Robert's uh left short sleeve to his
midline to where the buttons on his
shirt are and from the from his right
short sleeve also to the midline offset
from one another these um this is the
sort of stitching that looks like
perhaps I had been at the sewing machine
um and not somebody with uh skilled but
they did a good job basically of putting
it back together why are those stitches
in your shirt tell us about the stroke
and let's let's talk about
neuroplasticity it could also seem like
a fashion statement you know but it
really is isn't um well it was May of
2018 it was my birthday and my wife gave
me this shirt I have a love of plaids
it's like I don't know why I just love
patterns and plaids it must be like some
Scotch part of me some ancestor thing
but I love plaids can I interrupt you
just briefly forgive me everyone's going
to get upset that interrupt do you know
that there is a fundamental circuit in
your visual cortex designed to detect
plaid patterns no I did not know yes and
we can talk about why that is it's
tightly tightly linked to your ability
to perceive motion really yeah and we
can go over it some other time but yeah
so we'll talk about just as a Quee so
okay yes back to your birthday okay so
she gave me a plaid shirt knowing how
much I loved it and I love this shirt I
love the colors in it etc etc and then
two months three months later August 17
2018 I was driving my car she was with
me I was pulling out into traffic I
started driving and suddenly she's
saying pull up Robert pull over go why
why I can drive I'm fine and then
suddenly everything started getting
really strange everything looked strange
my voice didn't sound the same and she
was like freaking out but she was
actually fairly calm which was amazing I
was undergoing a stroke I had a blood
clot that was blocking the bra blood
flow to my brain I actually at one point
got out of the car like I was I don't
know what the hell I was thinking and
and then she pulled me back in then the
rest goes blank and I had some weird
Sensations that still remain with me
because essentially I was on the verge
of dying because blood not flowing to
your brain is basically the end of you
right unless something happens very
quickly and she either that or you're
going to get severe brain damage so she
called 911 right away she recognized
something my whole face was looking
funny and they got there
I was unconscious and essentially they
took this shirt and I just scissored the
thing in half and took it off my head
and then they intubated me I believe in
my hip area to get something the blood
clot was in my neck and they were able
to free it up and they rush me to the
hospital
and I'm unconscious and then um I wake
up and I'm in a gurnie in the hospital
and I don't for a moment I'm thinking
maybe I'm dead
because I'm lying in a gurnie and I
almost feel like I'm in a coffin I don't
know what's going on and I have all of
these weird
Sensations and I I tell people we're so
curious about death we think about death
a lot and you know is it final what does
it mean we really should pay attention
to dying dying is actually much more
interesting in some ways than death and
people who have died go through a
process if it if it's long enough and
people who have had near-death
experiences like I do have gone through
that process of dying and have come back
to life and in the process of
dying strange things happen to the brain
right so particularly with a stroke or
something like that where blood stops
flowing to your oxygen stops flowing to
your brain you have kind of visions and
things that you might think are
hallucinations but that later seem like
actually you are actually glimpsing the
reality as opposed to the illusion that
the brain creates so I've written about
this in my new book but um my idea of
the brain is that it creates endless
series of Illusions for you it creates
this seamless version of reality the
sense of a self the sense of a
continuous self Through Time right it
creates a linear sense of time
progressions it creates colors it
creates a world that visually you can
seems familiar and etc etc but it's all
illusion it's all a construction right
images come into your brain and they're
not organized in any way and the Brain
organizes in a way that you can
understand it well when you're dying all
of that scrambles up and you actually
are seeing something else so I saw for
instance that I really don't have a self
that it doesn't really actually exist
that I'm and the image that came to my
mind mind cuz it was in sitting in that
gurnie was a weird feeling
of like I can almost not explain it but
it's as if you took an image of
something real in the world and you
completely scrambled it up and it was
all wavy and you couldn't see what
exactly it was to me that was the image
I had of the self there are like 50
different selves inside of you that are
all competing and you think there's just
one and you think it's consistent but
there's not it's illusion the self is
literally an illusion that your brain
constructs when you're dying you see
these things when you're dying you see
other things like that you see that time
is something very weird so I had an
experience of when I got out of the car
and I got pulled in I thought like 10
seconds had passed my wife told me no
those this was like 10 minutes I had no
sense of time everything was scrambled
and so it was very very El it taught me
so much things that I can I can barely
even express now I'm always now thinking
of strange things that come to me
because my brain was damaged it made me
realize that the brain creates
everything so I can't communicate with
my hand my fingers I can't communicate
my brain can't communicate with my leg
right so you think that walking and
writing and handling things is just your
your body operating a certain way it's
your brain telling you how to move these
different things when that brain stops
functioning you realize how much your
brain determines everything it all
starts there and when there's damage to
your brain your whole thinking Alters
Etc not to mention how you look at life
itself after something like that so it
was a terrible experience it's ruined so
many things that I loved in life but
it's given me an awful lot as well in
return that I I could go on for hours
and talk about because it was the most
powerful experience of my
life when you were going through your
reemergence to Consciousness in the
hospital did you feel as if you were
observing these multiple versions of
yourself um maybe a different way to
phrase it is did you feel you were sort
of behind the circuit board that is your
brain observing how you normally
function and you could see multiple
versions of self or was it something
else where you sort of outside of your
body and brain I think it was more
outside of my body and brain I also had
this other thing that happened
where I you know sometimes you can't REM
your memory might be playing tricks on
you so I've also have to realize that
maybe I'm not remembering exactly what
happened or that I've since translated
in a different way so that's a caveat
here and I'm aware of it but I had this
Vision that I was dead at first when I
first became conscious and that I was up
in the sky and I was looking down and my
mother and my wife were talking and it's
like over my grave I suppose and I had
this feeling ah everything's okay I'm
gone but life goes on they're they're
doing fine it's okay right so I don't
know about that sense of self whether it
was like I'm aware of it happening but I
have a feeling it was something from the
outside I don't really know the answer
to that because it's very confused the
other feeling I had was life when I was
having the stroke was life draining out
of me and my bones getting softer and
softer and softer and I can't really
logically explain that the feeling of
Bones softening up and
dissolving but for weeks and months
afterwards I could access that feeling
of my bones dissolving Etc it was a
feeling
of all your energy draining out out of
you and you're dying literally so um
reading books about near-death
experiences CU that's a lot of what I'm
big part of my next book God is it's
fascinating there's so many interesting
things to go in because it teaches us so
much I'm so glad a you survived your
stroke B that your mental faculties he's
not more grateful than I am I tell I I
probably not but still very grateful so
there it just um illustrates how
grateful you must be um
B that you've maintained if not grown
your mental faculties I mean you seem
extremely sharp um I promise you you're
not missing a beat uh you know one
always wonders right actually one of the
most common fears people have is that
somehow they're losing their mind or
their memory and people aren't and they
aren't aware of it you know you hear I
have family members who have asked that
if they ever start to exhibit signs of
severe dementia that I um well put an
end to them which I won't um that's not
my place in this world um but I think
it's a common fear among among people
but you're still extremely sharp uh and
thank goodness for it and you mentioned
that um while you've lost certain
abilities that new appreciation and new
abilities have surfaced um could you
perhaps share what some of those are and
and what they mean to you um because I
think that when one hears about somebody
having a stroke we tend to focus on
what's what's lacking but clearly this
has been a transformative experience
also in positive ways well uh I had to
confront some of my own demons I had to
confront the sense that um I expected
things out of life and here they're
taken away and I'm I'm I'm kind of
ungrateful for being alive and here I'm
pissed off that it takes me 10 minutes
to time my shoes and I can't really
button my shirt I had to learn what
really matters and to have patience and
stuff the other thing
was I used to love hiking I was very
physically active and I'm sitting at my
window in my office I'm see see people
running up and down bicycling walking
their dogs God I'm so envious if I had
if I could walk a dog right now I'd be
the happiest person alive but then I go
through a thought process which maybe
isn't completely healthy which is
they're not aware of how wonderful it is
just to walk a dog but I'm aware of it
so when I go out in my backyard and I
can't walk and I'm seeing like I know
this is going to sound really Tria and
sentimental but I see you know
butterflies or things in my garden I'm
like wow that's incredible you know
things like that that I I couldn't
appreciate before because I'm I'm
sedentary and I can't move I have to
suddenly pay attention to what's around
me not take it for granted and find and
suck all the pleasure out of it that I
can so now when I sit at my desk to
write my new book it's 4 hours because
that's all I can stand maybe three
sometimes those four hours are like such
Bliss for me I truly appreciate it now
because I know that my brain was almost
gone right so it means so much for me
and to just be alive you know is is is
is just a wondrous experience I have a
chapter in my new book called awaken to
the strangeness of being alive and it's
about the fact that if you think about
it and how unlikely it is that we humans
evolved at all even that we even exist
all the bottlenecks and evolution that
we had to pass through including The
Disappearance of the dinosaurs and the
emergence of mammals but there are 20
other huge bottlenecks throughout the
history of evolution we had to pass
through all of those we nearly went
extinct 80,000 years ago from some virus
that infected there were only 8,000
people humans on the planet all these
different things and here we are with
zoom meetings etc etc it's like the
strangest story you can ever it's beyond
science fiction but nobody thinks about
it nobody sits down and goes God I'm
alive if you went back did the chain of
people that had to connect and have
children leading up to your parents the
unlikeliness of you ever being born is
astronomical I mean unless my science is
all wrong you know 70,000 generations of
people meeting etc etc finally ending at
your DNA I mean unless I'm missing
something it's it's pretty
unlikely but nobody thinks about it well
I certainly think about it now
because I almost died I have nothing
else to think about that's I have to
entertain my brain the way Milton
Ericson had to entertain himself by
observing people so it's taken a lot
away from me I can't swim I'm riding my
my recumbent bike which I love
and 80-year-old grandmothers are zipping
by me and God damn it how awful I'm so
envious I'm so my insecurities is all
well up but then I realiz hey I'm I'm
like I'm I'm like on a boat I'm sailing
it's wonderful I'm outside you know I
have to go through these processes but I
think it's developed me in some way
that's that's in the end very positive
sounds like you've had to adjust to a
new frame rate on life like the the the
old movie had a certain frame rate this
movie has a certain frame frame rate but
that within that frame rate there are
gifts to be had that you certainly
missed in your prior version of self is
that is that a bur yeah but also like I
tell people this I totally took my life
for granted I I was swimming all this
time I was fantastic I was bicycling I
was traveling but I never sat back and
thought W this is wonderful how grateful
it is could be taken away from you I
tell people don't do that to yourself I
try and teach them it can be taken away
from tomorrow when you're out walking
the dog think of me think of me that
can't walk the dog and appreciate those
things which I didn't appreciate so I
try and help people in that way when I
can you know I I think uh critical
message is also to inspire a sense of
urgency in people you know I think
people hear a sense of urgency and they
go oh God I'm already under so much
pressure life's so hard but we're not
talking about a sense of urgency to take
on more what life has to offer uh I
think we're talking about a sense of
urgency to find one's purpose which
takes work and is an ongoing process but
to really get out of modes of apathy
laziness um
languishing and to start as you've
described it paying deeper attention I
mean this is a a concept that was super
important for me to hear about and I
learned about it from was how do you get
yourself out of a rut you start paying
deeper attention to the things around
you and inside you and um perhaps not
coincidentally you referred to that as
quote death ground yeah so um it's what
it's a strategy from my book I wrote
wrote a book on strategy my version of
The Art of War it's called 33 Strategies
of War but it's really about strategy
the Strategic thinking it's inspired
from sunu the great Chinese strategist
but it has vast philosophical
implications the idea
is you can almost think of it like
barometric pressure when necessity is
pressing in on you like your back is
against the wall like you have to get
something done and there's like this
pressure around you you find energy in
there that you never believed before
William James talks about this when he
talks about getting a second wind
explains it very eloquently when you
feel like your life's in danger suddenly
you can you can leap over things that
you never could leap over before so
sunsu says put an Army on death ground
and it will fight and until it's it wins
meaning put an army with its back to the
ocean or a back to the mountain and it's
either win or die they're going to fight
10 times harder you're going to find the
energy in you that you normally lack
when death is facing ing you in the face
or urgency or deadlines or people
pressing in on you when that barometric
pressure loosens up and there's none of
it you think you have all the time in
the world you get nothing
done wow man I'm
23 I've got all these years ahead of me
I'm going to figure it out right I'm not
going to die I got 50 70 80 years ahead
of me no you don't that pressure now is
gone and you're wasting time you're
you're you're doing all sorts of things
that aren't leading to any kind of skill
you're not learning or anything you need
to put yourself on death ground you need
to feel that barometric pressure which
is the actual reality the actual reality
is you could die tomorrow you could have
a stroke tomorrow you you could be fired
tomorrow everything could fall apart you
need to have that sense of urgency now
because that's the reality you're
fooling yourself by thinking you have
all of this time and so when you feel
that
pressure suddenly you can move mountains
you you have energy your life you know
you just have Focus Etc neurologically
everything Clicks in you know and people
who've had that experience where they've
where they've felt like the the ship was
going under and they better get their
act together and survive they talk about
all these physical processes I have a
story in my new book I I hope I'm not
boring you with all no quite the
opposite about a mountain
climber who
um he he he was climbing this mountain
by himself and he was having a great
time but there was a storm coming and he
had to get down and he suddenly fell and
he cut his leg open massively and there
was like a branch sticking in it and he
he broke all these bones and he was he
was going to die he was on a Ledge he
could see that it was getting dark and
and storm clouds were were massing there
was going to be this was in the Rocky
Mountain Mountain he was alone and
suddenly he managed to get up on his two
feet and he can't explain how but all of
this energy all this adrenaline started
flowing in him and he said he was like a
mountain goat he was like going down the
ledge he he jumped he was able to kind
of get down to another ledge he he got
he got out of it and for the for the
next 20 years it was haunted by how did
that happen I want that feeling again
because it was actually the most static
feeling I had energy that I never
suspected in myself and so he tries
everything to get that feeling back he
tries climbing other mounts he tries
going to to Mount Everest he tries and
it doesn't come back and finally he kind
of figures out the formula for it and
why it happened he studies a lot of
Neuroscience it's a great book I'm using
it in my new book it's called bone bone
games it's very interesting book a lot
of Science in it um and he got the
feeling back in a smaller sense but it
was the feeling of your life is in
danger I better get my act together or
it's the end and suddenly adrenaline
dopamine all the other things were
occurring in him and he got and and he
found that energy so um that's that's
the ultimate kind of death ground right
there the human will to live is truly
incredible and so now I have to
say as I said before I'm so grateful
that your stroke didn't take you out
because clearly there's still so much in
there and you're continuing to share uh
what is really
exquisitly useful knowledge oh thank you
it's just it's just kind of astonishing
to me I started off today's discussion
expressing my gratitude for what you've
already done for my life and for the
lives of so many other people through
your books you know it's clear you've
been on a a foraging exploration and
that foraging for organizing and
communicating information mainly in the
form of written books but also online
content you have a terrific YouTube
channel which I subscribe to and follow
and um and listen to um with wrapped
attention uh and the other venues with
which you share information including
this one today are really truly valuable
and appre appreciated so I I want to say
on behalf of myself and um for those
that have known you and your work for a
number of years but also for the many
people that are now sure to um know who
you are and what you're about that it's
just so clear that like this stuff comes
from the heart and that it whatever
early seed planted this you know um that
we're all grateful for and better off as
a consequence of that that seed so uh I
could make this list very very long with
the the number number of specific ways
in which you've um improved the journey
through life and made it clearer I mean
you know life is certainly can be hard
but it also can be really confusing and
I feel that the the Robert Green uh road
map even though it's but one road map is
an extremely valuable map to have and to
use certainly has been for me so um just
an enormous thank you Robert thanks for
sharing today and thanks for all you do
and all that you're still still doing
and sure to do in the future oh thank
you I I wish I could find the word for
explaining the kind of weird emotions
that I'm feeling when I hear that there
isn't maybe Yiddish maybe for Clem or
something I don't know but thank you
yeah well we'll have to have you back
here again uh when your next book comes
out um can't wait but we will wait okay
yeah hopefully I'm still around I I I'm
confident you will be okay okay good
thank you come back again thanks very
much I hope I will thank you for joining
me for today's discussion with Robert
Green I hope you found the conversation
to be as stimulating as I did if you're
learning from and are enjoying this
podcast please subscribe to our YouTube
channel that's a terrific zeroc cost way
to support us in addition please
subscribe to the podcast on both Spotify
and apple and on both Spotify and apple
you can leave us up to a five-star
review please also check out the
sponsors mentioned at the beginning and
throughout today's episode that's the
best way to support this podcast if you
have questions for me or comments about
the podcast podcast or guests or topics
that you'd like me to consider for the
hubman Lab podcast please put those in
the comment section on YouTube I do read
all the comments not on today's episode
but on many previous episodes of The
hubman Lab podcast we discuss
supplements while supplements aren't
necessary for everybody many people
derive tremendous benefit from them for
things like improving sleep for hormone
support and for Focus to see the
supplements discussed on the hubman Lab
podcast you can go to live momentus
spelled o us so that's Liv mous.com
huberman if you're not already following
me on social media I am hubman lab on
all social media platforms so that's
Instagram X threads LinkedIn and
Facebook and on all those platforms I
discuss science and science related
tools some of which overlaps with the
content of the hubman Lab podcast but
much of which is distinct from the
content on the hubman Lab podcast again
it's hubman lab on all social media
platforms if you haven't already
subscribed to our monthly neural network
newsletter the neural network newsletter
is a zeroc cost monthly newsletter that
includes podcast summaries as well as
toolkits the toolkits are brief PDFs
that you can download that give you
tools for things like neuroplasticity
and learning for managing dopamine for
enhancing sleep for physical performance
flexibility deliberate cold exposure and
on and on to join the neural network
newsletter you simply go to hubman
lab.com go to the menu tab scroll down
to newsletter and enter your email we do
not share your email with anybody thank
you once again for joining me for
today's discussion with Robert Green and
last but certainly not least thank you
for your interest in science
[Music]